Guten Morgen Nino. Guten Morgen Tim.
Was ja schon immer mal wissen wollte, wie aufgeschlossen bist du gegenüber Neuen? Wie perfektionistisch bist du? Wie gesellig bist du? Wie rücksichtsvoll und kooperativ bist du und bist du leicht verletzlich.
Folgst du mir etwa nicht auf Facebook?
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer zweihundertdrei ein Wochenende mussten wir überspringen, aber äh ja bemühen uns ja immer hier im Wochenrhythmus äh zu bleiben,
ist irgendwas passiert. Ich glaube.
Ich weiß, ich hatte kein Internet.
Das war das war die absolute Linus Neumann äh,
wie soll man sagen Ereignis Woche, also man kriegt ja auf welchem Kanalknopf man auch drückte überall,
sprachst du zu einem und äh hast du Reden gehalten? Jetzt sogar auch auf Facebook.
Ich wollte mich gerade noch rüben, dass sie nicht bei Facebook bin. Ja, stimmt.
Ja, nee, nee, da können wir irgendwie äh alles über dich herausfinden. Da werden wir dann auch gleich nochmal äh genauer drauf,
eingehen. Fangen wir an mit äh vielleicht etwas äh Feedback, hat ja mal wieder nicht alles gestimmt, was wir gesagt haben. Was komisch ist, oder? Dabei sind wir immer so genau und.
Als Alternativmedium die Wahrheit, ne? Wir sind ja hier wir sind ja die einzigen, die wirklich sagen, wie es ist.
Alle anderen Lügen ja nur. Ähm also wir haben eine Korrektur, die liegt ein bisschen zurück, also nicht alle hörenden äh hören die Folgen ja sofort nach ähm nach Veröffentlichung. Was natürlich also was eigentlich nicht okay ist,
Also eigentlich wollen wir schon, dass das sofort gehört wird. Dafür machen wir uns die Arbeit, ja? Aber ähm ich wurde auf Twitter darauf hingewiesen, dass sich in einer vorangegangenen Sendung gesagt habe, dass äh alle
Parteien sich von dem Einsatz von Social Bots distanziert hätten bis auf die AfD und wir wurden,
Und ich wurde darauf aufmerksam gemacht, dass es eine äh Pressemitteilung der AfD gibt, äh aus Oktober zwanzig sechzehn, die sagt F,
lehnt Einsatz von sogenannten Social Bots ab. Äh da hat also äh Bundesvorstandsmitglied gesagt, ähm.
Dass sie diese solche Social Bots äh nicht beabsichtigen einzusetzen.
Das machen sie dann bestimmt über dritte oder.
Du ja also das machst du natürlich nicht äh nicht offiziell, ne? Das. Und aber man muss auch sagen, so, ich mein, selbst wenn jetzt die CDU sagt, wir wir wollen, wir setzen keine Social Bots ein oder die AfD, hindert das natürlich niemanden daran, dass trotzdem zu tun
Ja, also kannst ja jetzt nicht irgendwie, das ist ja das Schöne am Cyber, dass das immer so schwer atribuierbar ist, ne.
Der Cyber ist überall.
Überall und nirgendswo und da kommen wir halt irgendwie, also,
Das ist halt eine äh ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass sie's trotzdem tun, aber wir kommen in diesem ganzen Rahmen äh nachher noch ein bisschen weiter dazu. Dann äh.
Haben wir ja auch zur letzten Sendung wieder viele Kommentare gehabt. Auch da lohnt sich äh das Vorbeischauen.
Ähm in den äh in der Kommentarspalte bei Logbuch Netzpolitik DE. Wo nach wie vor,
im Gegensatz zu vielen anderen Kommentarspalten dieser Erde ähm Anstand und ordentlicher Umgang miteinander herrschen. Mir ist das jetzt gerade wieder aufgefallen. Ich habe, was ich ja wirklich sehr selten mache, mal wieder einen Text geschrieben.
Und ähm ich hatte das ja vor einiger Zeit schon mal äh oder ich glaube sogar es einige Zeit, es war halt die letzte Sendung gesagt, dass man bei den Podcasts in der Regel,
nicht bei allen, aber in der Regel die freundlichen äh das freundlichere Feedback bekommt, als bei Texten. Und das ist mir jetzt wieder äh auf.
Wahr geworden.
Das ist mir jetzt wieder aufgefallen, sobald du was schreibst, äh bist du äh bist du in, bist du in in die Tiefen hinabgestiegen? Also da, ja, trittst du dir Leute ein.
Musst du direkt in die Trollhölle durchgereicht.
Ja. Oder wenn du, wenn du über Trump speist, dann trittst du dir auch Leute ein.
Das äh soll auch passieren, ne?
Wir haben also bei Logboot Netzkritik immer noch eine äh halbwegs ordentliche Kommentarkultur, wo man respektvoll miteinander umgeht, auch wenn man unterschiedlicher Meinung ist.
Und so soll das auch bleiben.
So soll das bitte auch bleiben.
Genau, was im Übrigen auch grundsätzlich äh auch vielleicht auch Leute nochmal ermuntern sollte, weil es ist ja immer so Kommentare kommen ja traditionell.
Eigentlich immer eher über den äh über die Korrektur und über äh das da war was falsch
ja? Das ist ja auch nachvollziehbar, weil muss nicht unbedingt jetzt auch immer wieder betont werden, dass man alles genauso sieht und dass man irgendwie äh den Wahrheitsgehalt äh überprüft et cetera,
schadet aber auch manchmal gar nicht, äh auch solche äh Dinge zusammenzufassen, also wenn euch irgendwie mal danach ist, äh feel free, ja, auch ich finde das bildet eine Realität ab, weil so oder so halt
Kommentare auch verzerrend sind einfach so von, wie sie schon grundsätzlich aus äh angelegt sind.
Übrigens ähm einer unserer häufigsten und ich würde sagen, besten Kommentatoren ist Ade, ja? Und also ich weiß nicht, ob man AD oder At sagt, ähm.
Wir haben auf jeden Fall keinen AD-Blocker.
Unter jeder Sendung ähm inhaltliche Ergänzung und äh Kommentare, andere Perspektiven oder irgendwie.
Weiterfindest und häufig auch einfach das, was du da gesagt hast, ist falsch oder zu kurz gegriffen, immer im vernünftigen äh im vernünftigen Ton und es ist also äh eine Wonne.
Da könnt ihr euch eine Scheibe von abschneiden.
Nein, es ist wirklich eine Wonne, also das ist, ne, die besten Kommentare sind natürlich äh Widerspruch, Ergänzung, Korrektur.
Genau, aber da war halt irgendwie auch auf einer Art, die äh.
Im sachlichen Tonfall.
Konsumierbar ist.
Respekt vor allem, cooler, cooler Umgang. Haben wir, glaube ich, jetzt zum zweiten Mal schon gelobt, diese.
Ja, ja, das äh ist schon auffällig. Jetzt. Da steckt, da steckt was dahinter.
Ähm jetzt ärgern sich die ganzen anderen fünfundachtzig, jetzt ärgern sich die äh fünfundachtzig anderen Leute, die irgendwie kommentiert haben.
Ja, wir wollen hier nicht die Kommentierer des Monats ausrufen, das war jetzt hier nicht unsere Absicht.
Es geht nur darum oder mir ging's nur darum davor zu heben, dass eben genau der der Widerspruch und die Korrektur und die Ergänzung eigentlich natürlich, dass das äh wertvoll ist im Kommentar.
Genau.
Äh ein kleiner Nachtrag, das nicht nur so eine richtige Nachricht, aber wir hatten ja hier über Waldcomputer, Auffälligkeiten, kurz berichtet. Das war glaube ich Breaking News wirklich noch an dem Vormittag, als wir unsere Sendung aufgenommen haben,
wo
ne, diese Auffälligkeiten da waren und dann ist es ja dann in der Folge auch tatsächlich zu einer Neuauszählung gekommen, nicht aus dem Clintonlager heraus, sondern eben die Jill Stein hat sich dort äh in die Bresche geworfen, was auch immer ihre Motivation im Einzelnen dort
gewesen sein mag. Sie hat auf jeden Fall es geschafft, dann dafür Geld einzusammeln. Interessanterweise waren die Einnahmen dafür,
höher als ihre komplette Spendeneinnahmen für ihre Präsidentschaftswahlkampf vorher.
Ähm ja ähm das ist dann auch in äh zwei der Staaten tatsächlich gestartet worden. Allerdings reicht ja wohl das Geld dann nicht mehr für Penzelwellen, ja. Man kann also auf jeden Fall,
den Traum, äh dass das vielleicht in irgendeiner Form noch zur Revidierung des Wahlergebnisses führen könnte, kann man auf jeden Fall schon mal,
aufgeben. Interessant finde ich an der Stelle halt einerseits, dass äh dass in den USA ohnehin schon mal so ist, dass eine Neuauszählung der Stimmen,
von den Leuten, die das dann fordern, bezahlt werden muss, das äh da schüttelt man sich ja irgendwie auch, ja? Also das ist etwas, was wir hier in Deutschland so nicht
kennen und äh auch schon die Aussicht darauf, wie lange das dann dauert, fand ich irgendwie auch bemerkenswert. Ja, also ausgezählt wird es irgendwie in zwei Tagen, aber ein Recount soll dann irgendwie mehrere Wochen dauern,
man sich ja irgendwie auch was da äh falsch läuft und es war ja ohnehin die Frage und da bin ich jetzt auch mal gespannt, was zumindest diese ersten Ergebnisse dann,
bringen, wie äh zählt man halt einen Wahlcomputer nach. Das ist jetzt ausgerechnet für Penselvania nicht mehr gereicht hat. Ist doppelt schade.
Weil dort vor allem Wahlcomputer zum Einsatz kamen,
die eben auch noch nicht mal über diesen PayPal Trail verfügen, ja? Äh wenn ich nicht ganze Wahlcomputerdebatte
jetzt nochmal komplett aufrollen, da könnt ihr euch auch gerne nochmal bei früheren Sendungen hier bedienen, wo ihr das ausführlich dargelegt haben, warum das
grundsätzlichen Fehler ist unserer Auffassung nach und warum eigentlich auch PayPal Trail keine gute Idee ist, äh zumal es ja dann letzten Endes äh das
was die Wahrheit spricht, dann kann man's ja auch gleich drauf schreiben. Äh schade, dass es dazu nicht kommt, weil das wäre ja mal auch sehr interessant gesehen zu sehen, wie zählt man denn sozusagen einen Wahlcomputer nach?
Der ja gar keine andere Belege hat. Ausgerechnet dazu wird es also jetzt nicht kommen. Ist schade ähm,
sollte uns aber nicht davon abhalten, das Thema äh nicht weiter im Auge zu behalten.
Ja und dann äh war das Internet weg. Auf einmal gab's äh keins. Ich habe davon nichts gemerkt, obwohl ich ja Telekom äh Kunde bin, doppelter sogar.
Du hast ja eine Fritzbox im Einsatz.
Ich habe Fritzboxen im Einsatz und das war dann wahrscheinlich der Grund, dass ich äh nicht von dem Phänomen äh belästigt wurde, was so ein paar hunderttausend Deutsche in
als Telekom Kunden hatten, nämlich dass irgendwie auf einmal gar nichts mehr äh ging, so der
Rauterspukto keine Daten aus, alle wussten nicht, was äh Sache ist und die Telekom sah sich da eines größeren Problems gegenüber, musste auch schon so kostenlose äh LTE-Flats verteilen, um irgendwie alle noch bei Laune zu halten,
Ja und man fragte sich, was ist denn da passiert? Was macht man da? Da ruft man Linus an,
Und auf einmal Valinos überall Tagesschau, Facebook live, volles Programm.
Sehr schütteln mit dem Facebook.
Wie viel Uhr? Gleich noch was? Na ja.
Gleich nochmal zu. Also ich will mal ganz kurz erstmal erklären, was los war. Ähm das war ich glaube am letzten Wochenende gingen die ersten Meldungen in der Hinsicht los, dass bei bestimmten Telekom-Kunden,
Im Dirter verrückt spielten, so war der so war relativ schnell die erste Diagnose. Ähm,
man hatte kein Internet und die Empfehlung äh war dann den Router neu zu starten und die erste Fehlerbeschreibung war jo ging dann wieder einige Minuten und dann war's wieder weg,
Ja. Ähm dann gab's irgendwie Beschreibungen wie äh na ja, wenn du dir einen anderen DNS-Server setzt, als den, den der Router dir gibt
dann äh hasse wieder Internet. Ähm und dann gab's irgendwie eine Pressemitteilung der äh Telekom, die sagte er, da,
im Zusammenhang mit einem Hackerangriff. Ähm aber irgendwie war die Kommunikation dann auch so ein bisschen unklar. Und,
Ich saß also am vergangenen Montagabend äh,
war ich noch bei einer Konferenz in in Bremen und dann ging das so langsam los. Dann habe ich da auch nochmal mit einem mit einem Journalistenkollegen und so darüber gesprochen und wir haben irgendwie festgestellt,
es gab irgendwie so den die ersten Analysen zeigen darauf, dass es eine,
Eine Angriffswelle gerade gibt auf Port äh sieben fünf vier sieben. Wenn ich mich nicht täusche, habe ich das jetzt richtig in Erinnerung.
Fünf vier sieben.
Und dass das damit irgendwie im Zusammenhang steckte. Und dann habe ich,
mir gedacht, na ja okay, dann schauen wir mal, was da so los ist. Und habe einfach mal äh mich auf die Suche gemacht, wie mir diese Sache mir diese Sache anzuschauen. Dann habe ich also eine
eine meiner IP-Adressen genommen, einen meiner Server und hab mal Netcat einen Listener aufgemacht auf diesem Port und hab geguckt, was denn da so vorbeikommt.
Und äh es kommt vorbei, also,
Ein harte TP Request, ja, ist ja erstmal würde man jetzt eigentlich nicht erwarten auf äh sieben, fünf, vier, sieben, doch würde man schon, erkläre ich aber gleich,
Es kommt vorbei, ein HTP Rick Fest ähm der eine Sophe Arti bedienen möchte, also eine äh eine API, über die man mit dem Server kommuniziert,
im Format XML
ja. Ähm ich versuche das jetzt mal gezielt ein bisschen einfach vereinfacht zu erklären. Also es kommt ein HT, ein ein HTP Riekfest vorbei, der sagt, ich übertrage dir hiermit folgende Daten, ich möchte einen Post machen,
Und dann kommt da folgt ja so ein bisschen XML so und so und dann kommt das Feld äh New and TP Server,
und in diesem Feld steht dann in in Backticks ein ein Bash Befehl. CD, TMP, WGT, HTTP, äh, C Hart sieben, sieben sieben und dann ausführen. Und dann.
Okay, ja, ich versuche das jetzt nochmal in Ruhe genau zu erklären. Also jemand ein Befehl kommt auf diesem Port und sagt, ich bin.
Ich möchte dir eine,
Ich möchte dir mitteilen, etwas zu tun. Das, was ich dir mitteile zu tun heißt, setze dir einen neuen NTP Server. NTP, Network Time, Protokoll,
ist quasi das, wo du, wo dein Router herbekommt, wie viel Uhr es ist. Ja? Also auch,
Unsere Computer, die hier so sitzen, man muss die Uhr ja nicht mehr stellen, die holen sich das von einem NTP-Server aus dem Internet, kriegen die gesagt, wie viel Uhr es ist. Also der Befehl, der hier stattfindet, will offenbar einen NTP Server setzen, bei dem, der ihn empfängt,
Ähm ein NTP Server würde man setzen anhand einer IP-Adresse oder anhand einer Domain, also was was man in diesem Feld erwarten würde, wäre entweder eine IP Vier Adresse, eine IP V sechs Adresse oder ein Host nehmen,
Also sowas wie was weiß ich. Time Punkt haste nicht gesehen Punkt com,
Was aber in diesem Feld steht, ist ein ähm also etwas ein Escapeter Befehl in,
In einer Schellsprache, nämlich gehe in ein Verzeichnis, lade dir in dieses Verzeichnis eine Datei herunter, mache diese Datei ausführbar und führe sie dann aus. Ja? So, was das.
Zeigt, ist, dass offenbar ein Angreifer.
Eine Sicherheitslücke ausnutzen möchte in einem auf einem Port,
Äh wo es eine schwache Schwäche gibt und das dann ausgeführt wird, was der Angreifer nämlich da,
geschrieben hat. Ich erkläre das deshalb so ausführlich, weil das nachher eine Rolle spielt. Ähm wenn man sich ein bisschen mit so Routern auseinandergesetzt hat und ich habe ja, bin ja ein bisschen tätig in dem Bereich
Ähm, dann weiß man das auf diesem Port ähm ein Protokoll üblicherweise lauscht mit dem Namen TR null sechs neun,
Und TR null sechs neun ist eigentlich eine eine ganz gute Idee. Viele Ideen sind ja eigentlich ganz gut. Ähm und zwar ist die Idee.
Dass du als Netzbetreiber jetzt deinen Kunden diese Route da hinstellst, ja? Und die,
Unter Umständen möchtest du ja Konfigurationsänderungen
an diesen Routern vornehmen. Du möchtest denen vielleicht ein Update pushen? Ähm du möchtest den vielleicht eine neue eine neue Zugangskennung geben ähm oder andere Konfigurationseinstellungen an den Router ändern.
Äh die du quasi als Dienst am Kunden machst.
Oder du möchtest denen beibringen ein zweites Netz aufzumachen, damit sie noch als Hotspots für dich funktionieren oder so. Also quasi der Managementzugang auf den Router von Seiten des Netzbetreibers.
Kamama.
Kann man machen, jetzt gab's vorher schon Versuche mit anderen Protokollen, äh TR null sechs vier. Ich will jetzt nicht allzu sehr ins Detail gehen. Das Entscheidende bei TH null sechs neun ist,
dass das eigentlich der Port ist über den nachautentifizierung, du sagen kannst, komm bitte zurück, greife hier und hier zu, hole dir ein Update oder sonst was. Übrigens etwas, was die Telekom im weiteren Verlauf der Geschichte sehr gut gebrauchen konnte
Also da hat TH null sechs neun nochmal eine Rolle gespielt. Die Frage ist, wenn man sich diesen Request anschaut, würde man vermuten, okay.
Das, was auch immer dieses XML interpretiert, scheint eine Sicherheitslücke zu haben.
Die im Befehl des Sätzen eines NTP Servers auch etwas entgegennimmt, was keine IP-Adresse ist,
und weiterhin den Fehler macht, dass dann durchzureichen an eine Schell ähm,
Und dieses dann auszuführen. Also, die äh die äh Backklasse oder die Winobility-Klasse, von der wir hier reden würden, ist eine Command Injection. Ja, ich gebe einen anderen Wert, als das, was der,
Server dort erwartet und bringe ihn dadurch dazu,
etwas auszuführen, ja? Das was wir hier sehen, lade dir die Datei herunter von TR null sechs neun Punkt PW
und mache sie ausführbar und führe sie dann aus. Ähm heißt im Prinzip nichts anderes als oder deutet darauf hin, dass hier eine Schadsoftware Infektion stattfinden sollte.
Bei Geräten, die diese Sicherheitslücke im Sätzen eines NTP-Servers haben. Ähm, also bin ich hingegangen und habe mir diese,
Datei heruntergeladen, die mit der die Route sich offenbar laut Plan der Angreifer infizieren sollen. Und habe angefangen, die zu untersuchen und diese Datei macht als erstes ähm,
Als erstes diesen Port zu, wo ja die Sicherheitslücke ist, klassisches Verhalten von Angreifern, das wo ich reingekommen bin, mache ich erstmal zu, ich will das Ding ja jetzt für mich haben.
Und möchte dann äh im weiteren Verlauf den Router zum Teil eines Botnetzes machen. Also meldet sich dann bei einem Command and Control Server an, sagt hallo, ich bin ein neuer Bot und so weiter. Also was hier stattgefunden hat, ist eine Angriffswelle, die zum Ziel hatte
Die Route zu einem Botnetz zusammenzuschließen. Und zwar möglichst ohne, dass die betroffenen Nutzer das merken.
Das Rätsel der ganzen Angelegenheit war aber nun, dass ist ja nicht das, was bei dem Telekom-Routern passiert ist, was bei den Telekom-Router passiert ist, ist, dass die ausgegangen sind, beziehungsweise gecrasht sind oder,
noch spezifischer, dass offenbar der ähm,
der DNS-Musk, wie hieß er das auf Linux? Aber das sind keine Linosgräter, also der der lokale Domain Name Server,
Abgeschmiert ist bei diesen Geräten. Das war ja offenbar äh das, was was geschehen ist. Zu dem Zeitpunkt war klar, die Crashen aus irgendwelchen Gründen. Es war aber nicht ganz klar wieso.
Und die naheliegende ähm die naheliegende Interpretation wäre jetzt auf auf Anhieb, wenn man so ein Gerät nicht hat. Na ja irgendwas macht der Angreifer wahrscheinlich falsch. Die Command Injection ist entweder fehlerhaft,
oder das Binoy, was er runterlädt und ausführen möchte, crasht, irgendwas an diesem Angriff hat nicht funktioniert.
Oder es war überhaupt gar nicht diese Art von Gerät, die hier überhaupt äh angegriffen werden sollte.
Und das war das, was ich im weiteren Verlauf herausstellte, denn die die Theorie, die als erstes die äh die die Runde spielte, die von vielen Leuten.
Im Laufe des Montags ähm verbreitet wurde die sogar noch in den Tagesthemen am am Abend ähm gesendet wurde, wo sogar Professor äh Federat äh sie dargelegt hatte. Jemand, der äh durchaus Ahnung von IT-Security hat, war das also
die Telekom Router, diese Command Injection Lücke hätten.
Dass die Angreifer offen bei irgendeinem Fehler gemacht haben und dass deswegen die Router crashen. Also wir sind quasi hauthaarscharf an der Katastrophe vorbei.
Ähm,
Auch die, also auch ich hing dieser Theorie an, als ich dann nämlich mich analyse dieses Binaries machte. Ich saß, wie gesagt, ich war unterwegs, ich saß da im Zug und hab das irgendwie analysiert und hab versucht herauszufinden, was genau geht der Schieb, hat aber nicht so ein Gerät zur Hand,
ein äh sehr kluger ähm Hacker, ähm Ralf Philipp Weinmann ähm ist ein anderen Weg gegangen und hat gesagt, ich äh besorge mir so ein Gerät und gucke, was mit dem Ding los ist und was da passiert.
Ja, um welche Geräte ging's überhaupt.
Ähm Speedpott Router der deutschen Telekom vom Herrsch, die vom Hersteller Arcadien bereitgestellt wurden.
Dazu muss man sagen, Speedpott ist so eine Art Brand, das ist nicht wirklich immer derselbe Hersteller, sondern das ist sozusagen immer nur das, was die Telekom dir zu Hause hinstellt, damit du damit Netz machen kannst und das kommt mal von dem mal, von dem.
Von dem. Ja, deswegen waren auch Teil, also genau das war ganz klar, Fritzboxnutzer waren nicht betroffen. Es waren verschiedene Geräteklassen, Speedport, fünf null vier, sieben, hast du nicht gesehen, ich habe mir die Gerätenamen jetzt nicht so ähm im Detail gemerkt.
Aber jetzt hat Ralf sich also so ein Gerät geschnappt.
Und hat geguckt, was passiert denn eigentlich damit, ne? Und das erste was ihm aufgefallen ist, ist das massiv gepusht wurde ähm.
Softwareup jetzt von der Telekom, also er musste andauernd sein Gerät äh wieder downgraden äh um zu gucken, was da passierte. Aber das erste, was er gemacht hat.
Also weil das auch an einem richtigen Telekom Anschluss quasi getestet hat. Mhm.
So und das erste, was er gemacht hat, ist folgendes. Wer hat diesen Befehl genommen, diesen diesen vermutlichen Exploid oder diesen diesen eindeutigen Explort, äh zu dem es auch eine Wein Robility gibt, der es auch dokumentiert und so weiter und hat den gegen diesen Port geworfen?
Von diesen Telekom-Roter. Und hat festgestellt, der Crash nicht und der lädt auch nichts runter,
Und ähm der wird auch nicht infiziert.
Ähm was überraschend ist, weil irgendwo saßen ja äh äh neunhunderttausend Telekom-Roter, die nicht funktionierten und es schien mit dieser Angriffswelle zusammenzuhängen.
Ähm aber die erste die die erste Feststellung war A, dieses Gerät hat irgendein,
Ob's kures Betriebssystem ähm was auf jeden Fall kein Linux ist und was auch keine Schell bereitstellt,
und hat in Folge dessen auch nicht den den TR null sechs neun Server, der von dem zu erwarten wäre, dass er auch für diesen Explort anfällig ist,
was darauf hindeutete, dass dieser Angriff mit der Command Injection beim NTP Server sitzen, auf Port, haste nicht gesehen, dass das überhaupt nicht auf diese Plattform getargetet war, die diese Telekom-Router sind.
Sondern es ging einfach um andere Netzbetreiber irgendwo auf diesem Planeten. Irgendwelche anderen Geräte.
Irgendwelche anderen Geräte, die eine Win-Robility haben, die diese Telekom-Router nicht haben.
Das ist erstmal die die entscheidende Erkenntnis hier. Das heißt, die Telekom Router konnten auf diese Weise gar nicht von diesem Botnet infiziert werden.
Ihnen fehlte die Umgebung dafür.
Genau und da muss man einfach auch verstehen, dass das sozusagen solche Angriffe schon immer sehr maßgeschneidert sein müssen für bestimmte Geräte und wenn sie halt dann nicht passt, der Maßanzug, dann geht's halt meistens ins Leere.
Genau, also hier haben wir einen Angriff, der auf eine komplett andere Plattform abzielt, der aber trotzdem aufgrund dieses Ports bei diesen Telekom-Rootern ankommt.
Und ähm der noch dazu beim einmaligen Ausführen diesem Router völlig egal ist.
Und dann haben wir irgendwie so rumüberlegt, bis ich dann bis wir dann irgendwann äh,
auf die Idee kam, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wer von uns hier jetzt hatte, mir ist einfach nur aufgefallen, dass die sehr häufig kamen, diese Reques, also die der diese,
wenn man da mal so auf diesem Port gelauscht hat, kamen so alle paar Minuten, kam so ein kam so ein Request vorbei. Und dann hat äh äh Ralf Philipp einfach mal ähm den Mehrmals geschickt
Ja, also statt einmal und spezifisch zu analysieren, was passiert mit dem Gerät? Hat er einfach gesagt, okay, jetzt hauen wir den einfach mal zehn Mal hintereinander
und siehe da, äh die Geräte, das Gerät hörte auf zu zu antworten. Und stellte den Dienst ein. Ähm,
Das heißt ähm was der Telekom-Router nicht hatte, war die Wine Rebility zum Infizieren des Gerätes durch Command Injection.
Er hatte aber eine, die Nile of Service Wind Robility, weil auf dem Router,
einer oder mehrere Prozesse abgestürzt sind, die dazu geführt haben, dass er nicht mehr funktionierte,
Also eine andere Win-Rebility Klasse, ja? Die eine ist, ich kann bei dir Code ausführen, die andere ist, ich ich schaffe es, dass bei dir lebenswichtige Systeme abstürzen und du nicht mehr funktionierst.
Genau. Darf ich das von Security nochmal kurz in Deutsch übersetzen.
Habe ich doch gerade.
Nee, ich möchte mit einem Gleichmissantwor.
Oh, jetzt bin ich gespannt.
Ja, stellt euch mal vor, irgendjemand hat äh einen Generalschlüssel äh gebaut, von dem er festgestellt hat, dass viele Türen sich damit öffnen lassen. Und jetzt äh rennen alle mit diesem Generalschlüssel durch die Straßen und stecken das überall mal rein und probieren das irgendwie aus
das mag auch in irgendwelchen Ländern funktionieren, aber in deinem Häuserblock irgendwie äh geht keine einzige Tür auf, aber die Tür geht dabei kaputt,
und lässt sich danach vielleicht nicht mehr richtig aufschließen.
Okay, du hast so eine ist eine schöne, ein schönes Beispiel. Also er hat die Schlösser kaputt gemacht, ne. Ähm.
Habe sogar noch ein Anschlussbeispiel, was auch mit Schlüsselfuß gleich noch.
Oi
Ähm und jetzt war natürlich die Verwirrung groß, weil ähm.
Trotzdem ja der Schaden entstanden ist, dass neunhunderttausend Geräte offline waren. Also, was was passierte wirklich? Es gibt da draußen ein Botnet, dieses Botnet hatte äh den,
Befehl, sich zu vergrößern und hat deswegen aus allen möglichen Ländern,
Kriegtest du diese Request, ja? Ähm ich habe das bei mir dann auch mal so einen Tag laufen lassen oder in ein paar Stunden und habe geguckt, aus welchen Ländern kommen denn diese Requess? Also welche Länder
greifen meine IP-Adressen oder versuchen meine IP-Adressen da anzukrei.
Kommen die bösen Hacker her.
Das war so also jetzt ohne ohne Anspruch auf Vollständigkeit aus meiner Erinnerung, waren da glaube ich bei Italien, Großbritannien der Iran,
viele äh Brasilien, glaube ich und noch ein paar andere Länder. Aber keine einzige deutsche IP.
Ähm was darauf hindeutet, dass es in Deutschland keine infizierten Geräte gibt. Ähm weil,
Die Vermutung ist, dass dieses Bot Netz natürlich der Angreifer, der der Eigner dieses Bottnetzes, der macht die Angriffe ja nicht selber, weil wenn du ein Botnetz hast, dann lässt er das Botnetz das machen
Und was offenbar geschehen ist, ist dass äh dass die Angreifer ein relativ großes Bordnetz hatten und gesagt haben, jetzt marschierst du, liebes Sportnetz, also,
Meine lieben Tausende von Bots. Marschiert jetzt mal bitte durch den ähm IP, durch den V4 Adress Range.
Und schick diesen Befehl, diesen Exploid Code äh auf diesen Port und das ist offenbar relativ oft passiert, weil wie gesagt, so Wartezeit war zwischen ein und drei Minuten, wenn du diesen Port offen machtest, dass so ein Ding vorbeikommt.
Ähm und das einfach am laufenden Bande, ne und.
Wie gesagt, die Telekom-Route waren gegen den intendierten Effektimmun, hatten haben aber einen Back und ich weiß nicht, ob's inzwischen öffentlich ist, deswegen sage ich nicht genau, welcher es ist. Aber sie haben einen Bug im interpretieren dieses.
Dieses Drinks
Den sie eigentlich sowieso nicht ausführen, weil er äh quasi überhaupt nicht zu ihrer Implementierung passt und weil der vor der Authentifizierung ist und und und. Also das heißt,
Das, was der Angreifer da versucht hat, kann auf dem Pot gar nicht funktionieren, ist sowieso der falsche Befehl für den Port, den die für das Protokoll, was die Telekom beruht hat, das sprechen,
Und ähm sie man kann da sowieso nur andere Befehle geben. Das heißt, die Antwort, die der Telekom-Router eigentlich hätte geben müssen ist,
Entweder gar keine oder entschuldige mal bitte, wer bist du überhaupt, ja?
Weil es sogar Pre-of-Intecation war, das heißt, der Telekom-Router hat das, was ihm da gesagt wird, auch gar nicht überhaupt interpretiert, also nicht ausgeführt.
Aber er musste es passen.
Er musste quasi den Befehl verstehen, um äh oder den Befehl zumindest analysieren, um dann zu verstehen, hiermit habe ich nichts zu tun. Und schon an dieser Stelle also pre-Offenticacation.
Ist äh äh ist es eben äh ist das Gerät halt dann äh aus dem Tritt gekommen und dann das mehrmals hat eben genug Ressourcen in dem Gerät gefressen, dass es dann am Ende einen Crash gab,
der dazu führt hat, dass das Gerät nicht mehr funktioniert hat.
Hat man sich natürlich vor allem wieso dürfen die da überhaupt vorsprechen? Diese Freunde.
Richtig. Und das ist natürlich, das ist genau der Punkt, wo ich ähm oh ohne jetzt viel ins Detail zu gehen. Ich habe mich mit diesem TR nur sechs neun ein bisschen mehr befasst, als ich äh.
Also Theresien null sechs neun muss man das sein, das ist so ein so ein halbwegs standardisiertes Protokoll, wie man eben solche Netzzugangsgeräte von außen managt, wie man die
konfiguriert, wie man sie mit neuer Software ausstattet, im Prinzip so eine so eine Fernbedienung für diesen Rauter. Äh man kennt das ja vor allem aus den Kabelnetzen, wo das ja bis vor kurzem
ausschließlich so war, jetzt durch die neue Route Zwangsroute oder nicht Zwangsroute Gesetzgebung, die wir auch schon ein paar Mal besprochen haben
ist das ja im Prinzip jetzt aufgebrochen, das heißt, man darf jetzt selber wählen, trotzdem werden sehr viele Leute, das haben wir ja jetzt auch gerade bei diesen Dingen gesehen, äh beziehen schlicht einfach mal diese Hardware für den Netzzugang,
von dem Provider, bei dem sie eben auch äh den Vertrag haben und deswegen stehen die all überall rum und viele sind dann eben auch so eingestellt mit die Telekom oder wer auch immer der Provider ist, darf da soweit ran und das konfigurieren. Ja.
Ne, Moment, die sind dafür eingestellt, dass nur der Provider, also die Idee ist es, dass der Provider da dran darf.
Ja, nur der Provider. Genau und das ist, wenn man das akzeptiert, dann äh will man aber auch, dass auch nur der dran darf.
Genau, das ist genau das Problem. Und ähm ich habe,
wie gesagt in in meiner Beruf, in meinem beruflichen Bereich mich schon öfter mal mit sowas auseinandergesetzt, mit so TR null sechs neun. Und das war, wofür ich da üblicherweise dann sorge, ist, dass dieser Port natürlich nicht,
Einfach ans Internet gehängt wird, sodass jeder äh jeder andere IP-Adresse in dem großen, weiten Netz dort vorsprechen darf,
Weil du dir damit eben,
das Problem einfängst, dass unter Umständen jemand äh den Zugang brutforst, weil du wenn du irgendwelche Wein-Rebilities auf diesem Port hast, diese dem gesamten Internet zur Verfügung stellst und genau das ist hier jetzt auch geschehen.
Was du eigentlich machen musst
ähm ist über verschiedene Wege dafür sorgen, dass dass eben nicht das gesamte Internet da draußen bei deinem Gerät auf diesem Port,
vorsprechen kann. Zum Beispiel äh durch eine ACL Access Control ist, durch eine Firewall, dadurch, dass du den ganzen Port äh blockierst auf Seiten deines, auf der Seiten deines Netzes, Klammer auf. Das ist das, was die Telekom als allererstes getan hat. Äh und was sie auch tun musste.
Aber auch schon zwei Jahre vorher hätte tun können.
Was ihr, was sie auch schon vor vielen Jahren hätte tun können, als nämlich Nutzer in ihrem eigenen Forum sagten, ey, hallo, warum hängt ihr da einen Port ans Netz? Ich habe einen, ich habe einen Natrooter geholt, der V4 spricht und der macht irgendwelche Ports. Warum?
Warum kann jeder auf der Welt auf diesen Port zugreifen? Und die Antwort war dann eben so, na ja, äh sorry, der Port ist sicher.
What Coop Position?
Und auf eine gewisse Weise äh ist es sogar richtig, dass äh die Antwort lautet, dass jemand über diesen Port auf dein Gerät zugreift, ist unwahrscheinlich. Und es stimmt, es hat keiner geschafft, auf das Gerät zuzugreifen. Nur es gab halt eine äh Dine of Service Wein Rebility
ohne dass du überhaupt auf das Gerät zugreifst. Andere Geschichte. Ähm also was du eigentlich machst, wenn du so ein TR null sechs neun implementierst, ist du sorgst als Netzbetreiber dafür, weil es ja deine Back
ist oder deine Fronttour zu dem Gerät, was du beim Kunden stehen hast, dass auch nur du dahin kannst, du nagelst ihn zu, wie du willst, weil du weißt, wenn es da eine Wild Rebility gibt, dann sind meine hunderttausende oder Millionen Kunden betroffen,
Und ich muss die Scheiße auslöffeln. Also
sorgst du dafür sorgst du durch eine Firewall durch eine ACL oder durch sonstige Maßnahmen dafür, dass niemand anders überhaupt 'ne Verbindung zu diesem Port aufbauen kann als du. Wenn jetzt im Mobilfunkbereich bist
hast ja eh nochmal Carria Great Nut, also,
auf Seite des Netzbetreibers, das heißt, da ist es dann relativ einfach, ne? Da sagst du dann ähm okay äh,
Es gibt eh keine Portfreigaben bei uns oder so, ne? Wenn du äh richtiges Vier vergibst, dann machst du eben die Firewall-Regel bei dir zu Hause oder du sagst dem Gerät, pass auf, äh, wenn hier irgendeiner kommt, du nimmst nur von dieser einen IP-Adresse überhaupt Befehle entgegen
oder nur von.
Oder man sichert das sogar kryptografisch ab, was auch mal eine tolle Idee ge.
Die haben Menge, na ja Moment, das haben die haben da verschiedene Absicherungen drin gehabt. Das ist gerade noch etwas unerheblich, weil alles Pre-Ofentication war. Also was du ihn, du kannst es mit Zertifikaten sichern, der das geht ist alles spezifiziert.
Das war halt vorher schon kaputt.
Aber der Befehl kommt ja trotzdem an,
Und der Crash war, bevor es überhaupt irgendwelche Authentifizierungen oder sonst was gab. Der kam an, also das Gerät verhält sich ja dazu. Da kommt etwas an, dann muss es das ja nun mal prüfen,
ja? Und äh das war quasi schon hier der der Fehler, der den Nacken gebrochen hat. Und deswegen muss musst du, willst du, du willst einfach keine Ports offen haben,
Das äh haben sie eben.
Hier. Das war eben der Fehler, der der Telekom diesen Port überhaupt dem Internet zum Fraß vorzuwerfen,
Bis dann irgendwann äh ein Botnet so aus dem Fugen gerät, dass es die ganze Zeit auf diesen Port einballert und dein deine deine Dinale of Service Wahl Nobility Preofentication auf einmal neunhunderttausend Geräte in den Keller holen. Das hättest du halt
äh vermeiden können, wenn du den Port von vornherein zugeabt hättest. Hinzu kommt.
Keine Haustür sozusagen, die noch vor der Wohnungstür ist.
Ja, bleiben wir mal mit dabei deinem Schloss, das war schon ganz gut. Du hattest ein minderwertiges Schloss äh,
so oder hinzu kommt, dass jetzt dann noch eben die der Zulieferer der der Telekom,
Hier offenbar ein äh Mangel in der Software hatte, so dass diese äh gecrasht ist. Wie gesagt, ich weiß auch, welcher das genau ist, aber ich glaube, das ist noch nicht öffentlich und deswegen
werde ich das jetzt hier auch nicht erzählen. Entscheidend ist, das Gerät hat quasi beim Entgegennehmen dieses Befehls relativ früh.
Ein ein Crash her bei äh äh bekommen dadurch, dass da was ankommt oder in dieser Form, wie es ankommt und ähm hat dann dadurch den
den äh den Dienst eingestellt.
Ähm was die Telekom gemacht hat, ist folgendes, die haben ähm den den Port dann natürlich zugemacht auf auf Telekom Seite, das heißt nirgendwo im Telekomnetz mehr hast du diesen Port äh sieben, fünf, vier, sieben erreicht,
also bei keiner Telekom IP konntest du von außen an diesem Port connecten. Dadurch haben sie.
Quasi diese Nile of Serviceangriffe auf ihre Router ähm filtern können.
Und haben dann äh den Leuten gesagt, starte bitte dein Gerät neu und äh was dann passiert ist, ist das Gerät
hat er dann quasi das neue hochgekommen, diese ganze dieser alles Dienste sind wieder hochgefahren und dann ist die Telekom über den TR null sechs neu im Port gekommen und hat gesagt, übrigens, liebes Gerät, es gibt ein Softwareupdate für dich, hol das doch mal bitte ab.
Und bei TR null sechs neun ist das eigentlich so, du triggerst immer nur, dass das Gerät dann woanders hinkommt und sich die sich,
abholt, was es machen soll. Ja, das ist eigentlich die Schönheit bei bei TR null sechs neun, dass du ähm nicht den Befehl direkt gibst, sondern immer nur anklopfst, wie das die Telekom nennt und sagst, pass auf, du weißt ja, wo du hin musst,
Geh mal da vorbei. Ja, also im Prinzip sowas wie,
Es ist schon so kleingeschnitten, wie es eigentlich nur geht. Nur das kleine bisschen, was da entgegenkommt, das muss er trotzdem vernünftig passen können und wenn du das nicht richtig passt, dann schmiert dir halt was ab. Ähm,
Und das haben sie dann gemacht und dann haben diese Geräte äh sich geupdatet und äh mit der neuen Firmware, wo der Back raus war und äh jetzt ist das, jetzt ist das Problem gelöst.
Kam dieser dieser neue Firma nicht verdächtig schnell daher. Also ich meine, das machte ja so nicht so den Eindruck,
den Bag das erste Mal in ihrem Leben gesehen haben, dann sofort mit dem Hersteller kommuniziert haben, die dann sofort eine releasebare äh Version rausgebracht haben. Dieser Buckfix war doch schon vorher lag der auch schon im Regal und sie haben ihn bloß nicht eingespielt.
Bisschen so eine Verdächtigung, die ich gesehen habe, aber das ging mir alles so so schnell vonstatten. Also, weiß ich jetzt nicht mit Sicherheit, aber äh.
Wenn ich mir überlege, wie.
Das war doch nach einem Tag kam doch da schon neue Softwar.
Nee, das war ja ein bisschen länger.
Warst länger.
Innerhalb von vierundzwanzig Stunden, wenn ich mir überlege, äh wie wie schnell.
Ich der Sache mehr oder weniger auf den Grund gekommen bin und wie schnell vor allem Ralph Philipp mit Gerät in der Hand innerhalb weniger Stunden ziemlich genau sagen konnte, was da los war,
Würde ich das für eine realistische äh für einen realistischen Zeitrahmen halten, dass.
Dieser Zulieferer, der das Gerät herstellt und ein Team der Telekom, bei denen alle Alarmstufen an sind.
Ähm wahrscheinlich innerhalb weniger innerhalb kürzester Zeit in der Lage sind das zu reproduzieren. Erstens,
Und zweitens dann unter Vorliegen der Sourcen unter vorliegender kompletten Dibak-Umgebung,
für diese Geräte relativ schnell den Crash finden und den Back fixen. Das halte ich für ohne jetzt die genauen Zeitrahmen zu kennen, für eine realistische.
Also es ist zumindest denkbar, dass es so gelaufen ist.
Ja, also kann natürlich auch anders sein, kann sein, dass sie es die ganze Zeit wussten ähm aber das also.
Zu voll war, eine neue Version einzuspielen oder was weiß ich. Also okay, aber es wäre jetzt eine Unterstellung, dann äh lasse ich das jetzt mal äh weg. Ja, das machen wir jetzt nicht. Wir wollen hier.
Das Entscheidende, das Entscheidende ist, was man jetzt mal so sagen muss, okay, also die Telekom hat minder, hat ein, was sie jetzt auch immer noch sagen, sie sagen, es war eine Störung, es war eine Störung, ja. Nee, es war.
Bufferoverflow hat auch so in dieser Security Heine und von den Kameras irgendwie zitiert.
Wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht, wie der offizielle Stand ist, aber ich habe jetzt die Antwortung genug gemacht, dass da ein XML,
und der muss gepasst werden und dabei ist was schief gegangen. Ähm die.
Was die Geräte hatten, war ein fucking Back und dieser Buck ist eine Wilnobility gewesen, weil er, weil diese Value Billy dazu gefüttert hat, dass neunhunderttausend Geräte ausgefallen sind. Das ist nicht irgendwie witzig, ja? Da ist auch nicht irgendwie sowas wie Hu ähm,
Alles cool, die Telekom ist immun, ja? Also was sie jetzt sagen ist so, ha, die Angriffsfälle konnte uns überhaupt nichts. Ähm wir hatten nur eine leichte Störung, ja, eine Million unserer Kunden hatten zwei Tage kein Internet, aber sonst äh wir sind nicht Teil des B
Netzes, ja? Also das ist ähm das ist natürlich auch eine eine Interpretation, die äh,
die zulässig ist. Ich möchte sogar sagen, dass ich mich der Sache anschließe, wenn diese Router.
Ähm wenn diese neunhunderttausend Router jetzt zu einem Botnetz dazu gehören würden. Das wäre mit Sicherheit der schlimmere Ausgang der Angelegenheit.
Und das hätte auch nicht unbedingt jeder sofort gemerkt.
Das hätte nämlich nicht jeder gemerkt und dann hättest du mit neunhunderttausend äh Routern ähm am Telekom-Netz echt ein schönes Botnetz gehabt, ja? Und wenn wir uns an diese Dine of Serviceangriffe ähm,
zurückerinnern, die wir auch in der letzten Sendung besprochen haben, dann weißt du, was das ist, das Geringere übel ist,
mal eben neunhunderttausend Geräte für ein paar Tage ausgefallen sind. Aber das herunterzuspielen und zu sagen, wir sind sicher und uns kann nichts passieren, dass du den größten und längsten Ausfall kommt von Kommunikationsinfrastruktur in Deutschland,
Jemals hat es, wenn also glaube ich, ja, ich glaube nicht, dass irgendwo länger
und breiter das Internet ausgefallen ist, zumindest nicht das Kabelinternet. Ich glaube, es gab ja irgendwie mal öfter so Mobilfunknetz ist ja auch mal zwei Tage nicht funktioniert. Ähm da gab's ja dann auch Probleme. Übrigens auch bei der Telekom übrigens auch witzig
Waren waren auch keine Hacker, aber ähm anderes Thema. Ähm.
Es gab auch Vermutungen hier und da, dass es um was mit diesem Iran-Netzwerk, was wir hier in LMP hundertneunundne.
Das ist ein Bimmira-Angriff gewesen. Ja, ja, also der, der, äh, der, die Playlote äh wäre Mirai gewesen. Aber ne, also der Angriff selber kam ja auch vom Bodnet.
Ja, okay, gut. Dann stimmt das sozusagen. Wer dazu was wissen will, Doktbuch, Netzpolitik hundertneunundneunzig.
Ja. Also ich hoffe, da habe ich jetzt nichts falsch und ne, aber das wäre meine ich. Das war, das sah mir nach einer Mira Paylot aus, aber wir so.
Wenn du das sagst, also dann muss das ja stimmen.
Na ja, also entscheidend ist, entscheidend ist, die Nile of Service, Vinobility, zwei Jahre lang offenbar äh,
darauf hingewiesen, dass dieses Risiko besteht und ähm.
Nicht zu verachten ist die Tatsache, dass die Geräte diese Winobility hatten. Und dass es echt nicht witzig ist, wenn man sich jetzt mal überlegt, wie lange,
da das Internet für wie viele Kunden ausgefallen ist und die werden da jetzt nicht drüber nach Kochschwein gehabt, ich hatte es hätte schlimmer kommen können, ne? Schlimmer kann's immer kommen und wie die Telekom das Thema jetzt ähm.
Kleinredet, ist ein bisschen unredlich, weil,
wir eben einen relativ großen Ausfall hatten, finde für eine relativ große Kundengruppe. Ähm gleichzeitig würde ich sagen, dass die technische Antwort, die sie da geliefert haben und die Geschwindigkeit doch ähm.
Beachtlich ist. Also wie schnell sie in der Lage waren, ähm diese Sache zu erkennen,
den Backfix bereitzuhalten und dann aggressiv äh die die Updates gepusht haben. Äh das ist schon nicht im Bereich dessen, wo man noch groß kritisieren kann.
Sie sind im Prinzip mit ihrer Risp Ponstame schon im Bereich dessen, dass jetzt schon Verschwörungstheorien bestehen, dass sie den Bug schon den Backfix schon in der.
Ja ja genau.
Also da muss man dann auch wiederum sagen, das ist gut.
Ja.
Dass das Management auf technischer Seite äh macht hier einen guten Eindruck,
Sie haben das Problem relativ flux in den Griff bekommen. Das Management auf PR-Ebene finde ich eher fragwürdig, weil sie eben nach wie vor behaupten, es wäre nur eine Störung gewesen, denn alles halb so wild.
Und ähm weil es ja noch dazu dann irgendwie
will ich mich eigentlich gar nicht so äußern, hört Christ dann am, am Dienstag war ja dann auch noch der Security-Kongress der deutschen Telekom, wo sich dann der CEO hingestellt hat äh und sagte äh das Einzige, was hilft, ist nicht der Austausch von PowerPoint Präsentationen, das einzige was hilft, ist aufrüsten. Jeder einzelne muss aufrüsten
ähm und äh auf Heise steht dann äh der Telekom-Chef äh setzt nicht mehr auf reine Selbstregulierung.
Er hält den Aufbau einer CybernATO.
Salbernato.
Ist aber natürlich auch.
Das siehst du immer wieder, wenn äh wenn Unternehmen äh größere Unternehmen äh Probleme mit dem Cyber haben.
Dass sie dann äh im Nachgang der Geschichte das als ähm als Stärke umdeuten, ja? Sagen sie, wir haben
den wir haben den Cyber überlebt, wieder wir sind irgendwie kriegsgestellte Veteranen und jetzt jetzt machen wir jetzt werden wir hier die die generelle der NATO oder sowas, ne? Also das ist äh ist eine Strategie zu der ähm.
Wahrscheinlich ich ihm auch geraten hätte, äh wenn wenn er mich gefragt hätte, ne,
aber da muss man eben schauen so, das lässt sich nicht so einfach runterspielen, das ist hier eine eine ernsthafte Angelegenheit gewesen ähm.
Und äh man kann einerseits sagen, äh Glück im im Unglück.
Aber eigentlich eher so Unglück im Glück im Unglück, weil.
Ja.
Äh das war also das. Und ähm.
Da wurde ich dann auch irgendwie ein bisschen zu befragt in in verschiedenen Medien und habe da irgendwie diesen diesen diesen Teil dann so ein bisschen,
Nach aller Mühe versucht zu erklären und da kam es dann eben auch äh zu dieser misslichen Situation.
Angerufen hat und gesagt hat los ab ins Facebook mit dir.
Ja genau, das äh also das war so, dass die ähm.
War das misslich?
Na ja, ich war also erst war ich ja also ich habe da zu diesem Thema ein paar Interviews gegeben, weil ich ja
kurz zuvor im Deutschlandfunk mich nochmal zum allgemeinen Cyber geäußert hatte und dann natürlich entsprechende Anfragen oh der Neumann hat doch letzte Woche gesagt, hat bricht alles zusammen, es bricht glaube ich gerade zusammen, vielleicht fragen wir den mal, was er dazu sagt.
Da wird die Expertendatendatenbank nach äh Riesenlyst äh.
Unge
her und dadurch kam es dann, dass da ein paar äh ein paar Medienanfragen waren und äh die ich dann auch beantwortet habe. Auch ich habe übrigens anfangs äh diese frühreife Theorie äh noch äh erläutert, dass es da ähm also da war mir noch nicht der gesamte,
äh in seinem Ausmaß klar. In mir wusste, ich wusste, da läuft irgendwas schief,
Also es passiert nicht das, was die Angreifer beabsichtigen, aber ich wusste es noch nicht so genau, wie nach der Analyse äh die die Reifung durchgeführt hat. Auf jeden Fall war dann irgendwie auch äh Rief äh Carmen Mioska an. Kennst du, ne?
Ja. Tagesthem.
Tagesthemen. Und sagte ja können sie hier in der Sendung und so kommen sie mal vorbei und dann haben die, was ich.
Die rief selber an, die war sozusagen auch die.
Die hat erst also erst rief ein Resakteur an und dann sagte der, dann ruft die Frau Mioska sie gleich auch nochmal an, weil die das war jetzt dann tatsächlich live und dann wollen die wollen die so kurz sagen, die so grob, ich steige dann mit folgender Frage ein.
Ja, ist sie denn da, Chefredakteurin oder ist macht sie nur die Moderation oder wie ist das da, wie funktioniert.
Das weiß ich nicht genau, wer das ist, aber die als Moderatorin hat sie auf jeden Fall diese Tagesthemengespräche sind verhältnismäßig frei,
sie hat mir dann halt gesagt, okay, was was können sie denn so erzählen? Ähm okay, dann steige ich mit mit dieser Frage ein und dann unterhalten wir uns. So, äh darauf wollen wir aber gar nicht hinaus. Jetzt was ich ganz gut fand, ist,
dass dann sich die Social Media Redaktion der äh des von ARD aktuell bei mir meldete und sagte, ja können sie nicht vorher, wenn sie doch eh schon mal da sind im im Hauptstadtstudio ein Facebook-Live machen und ich sagte, was ist das? Und äh Facebook Live
geht so ähm die,
Die sitzt, du sitzt quasi dort, hast du kriegst ein iPad in der in die Hand und da können dann Zuschauer Fragen stellen. Und ähm dann liest du quasi diese Fragen ab und beantwortest sie in die Kamera. Und das Ganze wird dann über Facebook,
gestreamt. Und da sitzen dann halt Facebook-Leute und und gucken jetzt per Video zu und können da Fragen reinstellen.
Das sind ganz normale Menschen.
Normale Menschen wie du und ich nur, dass sie halt auf Facebook sind. Und die ähm schreiben dann äh schreiben dann also Fragen und ich fand das, ich habe war erst so ein bisschen skeptisch, aber ich fand das aus verschiedenen Gründen sehr gut, weil erstens,
Die Fragen waren interessant. Man konnte also man konnte in Ruhe sich mit den Leuten austauschen. Man hatte auch mal Ruhe ein bisschen auszuholen zu zu ähm.
Zu antworten und wenn man was unklar erklärt hatte, kamen direkte Nachfrage, dann konnte man also sehen, ah okay, den den Teil habe ich noch nicht ganz richtig beleuchtet und vor allem, was mir persönlich daran total gut gefallen hat, ist, ich stand zwanzig Minuten vor dieser dämlichen Kamera,
bis zu einem Punkt, der ist mir echt langsam langweilig wurde in dem ARD-Hauptstadtstudio nachts um zehn, ja? Und als dann eben die Tagesthemen an.
Also vorher stand so zwanzig Minuten rum und hat nix zu tun.
Ich habe nee, ich habe zwanzig Minuten in diese Kamera gesprochen. Solange.
Das meinst du erst okay, ne? Weil der Mitschnitt war nämlich, der Finger auch erstmal mit zehn Minuten öde an. Äh schlecht geschnitten. Ich dachte schon.
Ja, das ist irgendwie, weiß ich ja auch nicht genau, weil nee, das ist halt live, die haben halt, die schalten halt ihren ihren Kanal von dem Studio da drauf, aber wie dem auch sei.
Niemand sei ja zuerst nur kam in Mioska, die die ganze Zeit nur äh in.
Genau, die diese Sendung vorbereitet hat. Worauf ich hinaus möchte ist zu dem Zeitpunkt, als die Tagesthemen liefen, hatte ich schon zwanzig Minuten in diese Kamera gelabert,
dass dann irgendwann noch kamen, Yoscar kam und sagte, Herr Neumann, erklären sie nochmal ganz kurz, was sie die letzten zwanzig Minuten schon erklärt haben. Das war nicht so schlimm wie sonst, dass du da reingehst, äh irgendwie hektisch, hektisch dich einer da reinstellt, aus dem Raum geht
du auf diesen auf diesem Kreis da gucken muss und dann auf einmal.
Jetzt Experte drei zwo eins.
Drei zwei eins und dann hörst du auf morgen eine Minute noch, eine Minute noch und ich mein Tagesthemen ist halt eine Sendung, die gucken schon eine ganze Menge Leute.
Und deswegen finde ich dieses Facebook Live als äh vom psychologischen Effekt her äh fand ich das eine ganz gute Angelegenheit. Und damit rede ich mir jetzt schön, dass ich auf Facebook war.
Na ja gut, ich meine, ich will's jetzt auch mal gar nicht, also ich fand ja nicht, dass jetzt hier,
Das was du gemacht hast, war ja jetzt nicht sehr fest. Facebook spezifisch, außer, dass sozusagen sowohl das Streaming als auch die Chat Kommunikation halt innerhalb dieses Systems lief, ne. Ähm ja.
Aber ich finde das Format gut. Ich.
Auch gut, weil das war ja eigentlich auch schon immer so eine Kritik äh an diesen äh Rildheim-Medien, dass man halt äh einfach für bestimmte Sachen, die einfach Zeit brauchen, diese Zeit nicht hat und wenn das Netz dafür genutzt wird, äh an der Stelle so ein äh Zusatzkanal aufzumachen
alles super. Ich muss eh sagen Tagesschau finde ich war auch schon in meiner Wahrnehmung.
Immer ziemlich weit vorne. Also die haben sehr früh mit Blogs angefangen, die haben sehr früh korrekte Webseiten an Start gebracht.
Aber sehr spät mit Facebook. Die haben noch nicht mal eine Million, die haben noch nicht mal eine Million Follower auf Facebook.
Gut, das kann ich jetzt im Einzelnen nicht beurteilen. Grundsätzlich habe ich aber den Eindruck, dass dort schon ein äh Netzaffines Team ist. Nicht unbedingt in der ersten Reihe, aber auf jeden Fall äh mindestens im Angebot.
Formate und so weiter. Ich könnte da jetzt noch weit ausholen. Ähm ist auch nur so ein Gefühl. Anyway.
Ja, also das äh das war auf jeden Fall das und äh ich glaube, diese technische Analyse habe ich jetzt äh hier nochmal äh zum zum Besten gegeben.
Das war der aber entscheidende
Punkt ist eben diese. Das war alles andere als lustig, ne? Dass das da so viele Leute ausfallen und dass diese Idee das herunterzuspielen und diesen Spin, den die Telekom der Sache jetzt geben möchte, ist ein bisschen äh.
Unangemessen. Man kann einfach festhalten, die Telekom äh ist hier,
eigentlich ein Kollateralschaden gewesen, ist mit dem blauen Auge äh davon gekommen, weil sie's dann noch relativ schnell gehandelt bekommen haben
sie hätten es selber alles von vornherein verhindern können und eigentlich auch verhindern müssen, dass sie das nicht gemacht haben, war eine Unterlassung
Jetzt ist es wohl äh besser. Äh man kann nur hoffen, dass zukünftige Szenarien vielleicht äh äh früher eingegrenzt werden.
Genau,
So, jetzt haben wir lange genug über den über diesen Ausfall geredet. Ähm es gab noch ein anderes Thema, denn wenn ihr Infrastruktur ausfällt, dann ist natürlich das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz nicht fair,
ja? Ähm das ist ja jetzt also laut IT-Sicherheitsgesetz ähm ein meldepflichtiger Fall, ne? Ja, wenn ihr mir mal paar mal äh eine annähernder Millionen Leute das Internet we
Das ist äh das unterlicht an der Meldepflicht. Ähm kann man dann auch drüber witzeln, ich, mir fällt gerade, also nur am Rande ein,
Ich glaube in, in dem als die Anhörung zum IT-Sicherheitsgesetz im Innenausschuss war, da war auch der,
Thomas Schersig von der deutschen Telekom, der deren äh Head of IT Security auch als Sachverständiger neben mir,
jetzt wird er sehen, was er davon hat, dass er sich fürs IT-Sicherheitsgesetz. Nein, ähm.
Da musste ich nur gerade dran denken. Ähm wir sind beim beim nächsten Thema, denn äh der bayerische Rundfunk hat,
hat mal dieser ganzen Geschichte des IT-Sicherheitsgesetzes auf den Zahn geführt. Und zwar ist das ja so, dass ähm.
Dass dass sich die Betreiber kritischer Infrastrukturen ähm.
Anmelden müssen mit Alarmierungskontakten und so weiter, beim BSI,
Quarverordnung des Innenministeriums. Und das ging in verschiedenen Gittern in den verschiedenen Bereichen kritischer Infrastrukturen äh langsam los. Und die erste Verordnung.
In dem Bereich äh betraf die Sektoren Energie, Wasser, Ernährung und Informations und Kommunikationstechnologie. Und da wurde also gesagt, ihr habt bis zum dritten November Zeit, euch beim BSI zu registrieren
Und jetzt ist ganz interessant, dass ähm das BSI nämlich davon ausgegangen ist, dass es,
um die, um die vierhundertfünfzig besonders sensible Anlagen geht, die sich registrieren müssen.
Und ähm dann ist aber nicht für jede Anlage gibt's ja nicht nur einen Betreiber, sondern eventuell gött einem Betreiber mehrere Anlagen,
Und ähm zum Zeitpunkt dritter November hatten sich dann dreihundertzehn Anlagen ähm registriert,
Und jetzt haben die Journalisten eben die Frage gestellt, was ist denn mit den restlichen hundertvierzig
Die Antwort des BSIs, die Auswertungen der Anträge läuft noch und eine abschließende Bewertung ist äh nicht möglich, aber äh wir finden das auf jeden Fall schon mal positiv, dass wir so viel Rückmeldung bekommen haben,
Ähm und dann denkst du dir so, hä Moment mal, äh ihr müsst doch wissen.
Wie viele kritische Anlagen es überhaupt gibt.
Damit ihr bewerten könnt, wer sich bei euch gemeldet hat und wenn die Leute sich bis zum dritten November bei euch melden, dann habt ihr doch hoffentlich vorher angefangen, die Dinger zu zählen. Und das heißt, bei dem BSI gibt es zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt offenbar,
nachdem was sie sagen ähm entweder Problem A, nämlich um die einhundertvierzig.
Anlagen haben sich nicht registriert. Das heißt, diese gesamte Verordnung äh vom Innenministerium und so weiter wurde von einhundertvierzig Anlagenbetreibern einfach ignoriert,
leckt uns am Arsch, das könnte sein. Oder es gibt Problem B, das BSI hat noch nicht mal eine noch nicht mal einen Überblick,
Welche Anlagen es gibt, die die nach IT-Sicherheitsgesetz geschützt werden müssen?
Und die vierhundertfünfzig waren nur geraten.
Vierhundertfünfzig waren übern Daumen geschätzt in die haben überhaupt keine Ahnung was für kritische Infrastruktur gibt. Das mit anderen Worten hieße das du könntest als Betreiber kritischer Infrastruktur darauf hoffen,
BSI vielleicht gar nicht mitbekommen hat, dass du da ein Kernkraftwerk stehen hast. Oh, das war so ein bisschen äh zu übertreiben. Also,
Das ist natürlich schon der erste Schritt, um überhaupt irgendwie so eine.
Dachten, dass wenn überhaupt dachte, Golfplatz.
Ne der erste Schritt überhaupt so ein so ein Sicherheitsmanagement anzugehen wäre, dass du einen Überblick hast, ja? Also ohne Überblick kriegst du nichts hin,
Und also hier fehlt entweder der Überblick oder äh die die Hörigkeit der äh Betroffenen. Äh auf jeden Fall sieht es gerade nicht so gut aus für die groß angekündigte ähm,
für die Groß,
ja, genau. Also das nur am Rande. Aber dieses Thema ist natürlich jetzt auch sehr groß. Äh der BND schreit ja auch der Russe war's und äh,
oder der Russe kommt und ähm das Thema äh Cyber ist natürlich jetzt eine eine größere Angelegenheit und wird in den nächsten Wochen natürlich noch
mehrmals durch den Fleischwolf gedreht werden und von allen möglichen Ministerien jetzt auch nachgefragt werden. Insofern,
werden wir mal sehen, wie sich das in in Zukunft entwickelt, aber das viel mehr Themen thematisch nah auf.
Tja, da muss das BSI sich ein bisschen äh anstrengen, wenn man dann später die Cybernato dreimal klingelt so. Da müssen auch Antworten geliefert werden, ne.
Und die Freiwillige, die freiwillige Cyber, wer äh wer weiß nicht, dass die da irgendwann bei Frankly Fire.
Wir werden die alle verstört durch die Datennütze. Oh Mann, na das wird doch schön. Ich fühl mich jetzt schon viel sicherer.
Ja, dass das Problem ist.
Lassen wir das mit dieser Sicherheit. Ich will ich möchte ich bin dieser ganzen Sicherheitsgeschichte so ein bisschen zwiespätig,
stehe ich ihr gegenüber. Weil natürlich ist die Lage,
besorgniserregend, was die Softwarequalität angeht, was den politischen Rahmen dieses dieses Bereiches angeht, was das Schadenspotential angeht, weil das wir da sehen. Ähm.
Da muss auch was getan werden. Gleichzeitig ist aber die mediale Berichterstattung sehr gerne äh so,
überdramatisiert, ja? Äh deswegen war ich auch sehr froh, dass ich in den Tagesthemen da wirklich irgendwie dreieinhalb, vier Minuten Zeit hatte, den Fall aufzurollen, ja? Äh weil so viel Zeit brauchst du eben auch. Und die meisten ähm,
Medien oder viele mediale Berichterstattung ähm ist eben schon auf diesem äh wir werden alle äh Sterbenniveau und das wird's natürlich auch nicht. Gleichzeitig möchtest du aber auch nicht, dass alles immer nur so gehen, gehen sie weiter, hier gibt's nix zu sehen. Das war eine geringfügige Störung,
Also da äh das Themenfeld richtig zu erfassen. Und die notwendigen Maßnahmen einzuleiten,
Während man gleichzeitig nicht in diese Paniktröte bläst, äh ist glaube ich sehr wichtig, denn was die die Paniktröte hat den,
Nebeneffekt, dass genau das, was du auch äh was du siehst bei dieser Massenüberwachung
dass eben weil die Leute sagen, ja ja ist alles unsicher, schmiert alles zusammen, wir werden alle sterben, aber irgendwie lebe ich noch weiter. Also so schlimm kann's ja auch nicht sein. Ne, also es ist schlimm.
Und die der Apokalypsonat aber wir müssen irgendwie gucken wie der Smooth vor der Welle noch herreiten, ja?
Muss jetzt nicht unbedingt gleich die Mülltonnen in Brand setzen.
Genau und da irgendwie eine so Dringlichkeit und Handlung zu vermitteln.
Ohne gleichzeitig in diese Panik,
Sache zu fallen, ist wirklich ein ein sehr schmaler Grad. Der mal gelingt und mal nicht auch in dem äh was ich vielleicht zu den Themenfeld sagen kann oder nicht.
Auch das, was wir jetzt hier irgendwann mal ins Logbuch geschrieben haben, dass wir hier
unaufgeregt die Dinge begleiten wollen. Das äh gelingt ja mal mehr, mal weniger so, aber es ist schon das Ziel eigentlich, ja? Weil das ist ähm man merkt auch
Das geht, das, das kann man echt sehr viel weiter aufziehen, ne? Man kann,
Eigentlich in jeder Debatte, um so so kritische Themenlagen politischer Natur, ähm.
Ich merke immer wieder, es ist es ist dann doch sehr lohnend,
gerade so in langer Sicht, wenn man zurückblickt und äh festhält so okay, da habe ich dieses Thema zwar mit debattiert.
Aber ich bin jetzt auch nicht gleich losgerannt und hab irgendwie die Fackel geschwungen, weil sie später dann immer wieder schnell äh herausstellt so,
ne? Und jedes Mal, wenn mir das dann auch selber wieder passiert und auch mir passiert das manchmal. Ähm.
Ärgere ich mich hier sehr. Vor allem wenn man wenn man Maßnahmen ergriffen hat, die man danach auch nicht mehr so ohne Weiteres rückgängig machen kann.
Ich weiß nicht, was du jetzt damit meinst, welches, also welches.
Ne, so eine na ja äh einfach Debatten überhaupt unaufgeregt äh zu führen und eben sozusagen so dieses Jahr, ich ich thematisiere das, wie du es eben gesagt hast, ja, also dass man einfach sagt, ich,
ich kläre jetzt hier auf, ich äh beschönige nichts, ja, aber ich rufe auch nicht sofort äh,
sozusagen die Apokalypse herbei, dass jetzt sozusagen überhaupt nichts mehr äh zu retten ist. Das das kann man ja genauso gut auch für alle anderen Themenfelder auch äh rausbringen.
Hatte grade selber auch mal wieder so ein so ein Twitter-Ausrutscher, wo ich mich auch mal wieder von irgendeiner Nachricht, die überhaupt nicht über
war schon gar nicht von mir, äh habe verleiten lassen und einen Kommentar zu schreiben und wurde dann Gott sei Dank auch schnell von irgendjemand äh zurechtgewiesen, doch vielleicht erstmal die Füße stillzuhalten.
Pizzageld oder was?
Habe dann auch mein Tweet sofort gelöscht und ist äh sofort äh bereut, aber passiert halt manchmal. Womit wir schon fast bei Fake News werden.
Genau, da du wolltest eine Überleitung machen, okay, aber ich wir machen erstmal ein anderes Thema. Wie machen wir denn da jetzt die Überleitung hin?
Ach so. Falsch übergeleite.
Okay, ich weiter, worauf will der junge Mann hinaus.
Ich wollte nein äh hätte jetzt eine Überleitung sein können, aber das war jetzt einfach auch nochmal das, was ich dazu sagen kann, auch wenn du mich äh Fragen anguckst, wovon der Prittler jetzt schon wieder reden.
Okay, ja ich habe nur gedacht, äh wie möchtest du die Kurve kriegen? Ich dachte so äh.
Nee, ich wollte die Kurve gar nicht kriegen. Ich wollte es einfach nur mal äh hinzufügen.
Gut, kommen wir, kommen wir zum nächsten Thema, was aber, wo man da vielleicht passt es auch da, also wo jetzt auch eine eine Nachricht, die gerade sehr groß die.
Ja, das ist auch so eine.
Runde machte, ne, dass also wahrscheinlich passt es nämlich doch. Ähm und zwar.
Und zwei. Das stimmt.
Eigentlich sogar, ja doch, ich habe, ich stand auf dem Schlauch, du nicht, du warst klug, du hattest Voraussicht, Tim. Äh.
Die Sendung, die markiere ich mir rot im Podcast kleint.
Und zwar gibt es einen Artikel in dem Schweizer äh in der Schweizer Veröffentlichung in das Magazin. Äh nee, mit dem mit dem Titel.
Ich habe nur gezeigt, dass es die Bombe gibt. Äh der Psychologe Michael Kosinski hat eine Methode entwickelt, um Menschen anhand ihres Verhaltens auf Facebook minutiös zu analysieren,
Punkt und verhalf so Donald Trump zum Sieg.
So, im weiteren Verlauf dieses Artikels wird dargestellt, dass er ähm im Prinzip das Verhalten auf Facebook von Leuten.
Also insbesondere die Likes und so weiter analysiert hat und mit etwas in zur Vorhersage von etwas genutzt hat, was sich die Big Five nennt. Und ähm,
Um das zu erklären, muss ich jetzt einmal kurz einen kleinen Ex-Kurs in Psychologie machen.
Ähm der jetzt erstmal noch so kurz einmal Grundlagenwissen, ja? Ähm.
Unterwegs werde ich da noch ein paar faktische Fehler in diesem Artikel korrigieren, weil ich nicht anders kann. Ähm also ungefähr in den,
Also es gibt ja quasi die die Psychologie geht hin und möchte ja irgendwie äh erleben und Verhalten beschreiben
Unvorhersagen. Das ist die Wissenschaft der Psychologie, also Vorhersagen heißt dann am Ende eben auch natürlich beeinflussen können, ne?
Und jetzt sind wir hier im Bereich der Persönlichkeitspsychologie, was interessant ist, weil ich meine Zeit lang am Lehrstuhl für Persönlichkeitspsychologie der Humboldt-Universität zu Berlin gearbeitet habe.
So ein Zufall.
So ein Zufall, ja und äh auch äh Persönlichkeitspsychologie noch an weniger prestigeträchtigen äh Lehreinrichtungen eine Zeit lang äh äh den Leuten vermittelt habe. Ähm.
Was ist Persönlichkeit? Persönlichkeit ist ungefähr ähm die quasi das die Gesamtheit deiner Eigenschaften. Das, was dich, was die individuellen.
Merkmale deiner Person sind. Jetzt kommt natürlich die Frage, was ist eine Eigenschaft? Und äh der so die die naheliegendste App,
Erklärung von einer Eigenschaft ist im Prinzip eine ähm Verhaltenstendenz, ja? Also du sagst im Prinzip ähm.
Du bist ein freundlicher Mensch, du hast die Eigenschaft Freundlichkeit, wenn du regelmäßig,
freundliches Verhalten zeigst, also Eigenschaften sind Verhaltensdispositionen.
Mhm.
Ja? Äh so werden sie gängigerweise ähm interpretiert. Ich versuche jetzt äh spezifisch, dass ein bisschen ähm,
Eingängiger zu gestalten ohne den gesamten übertheoretischen Überbau der Persönlichkeitspsychologie. A.
Ich kann ja versuchen das dann später nochmal mit Schlüsselzeug.
Ja, okay, dann bin ich gespannt. Ähm.
Und jetzt könntest du zum Beispiel sagen, ne, Freundlichkeit wäre jetzt eine Eigenschaft, ist auch eine gängige Eigenschaft, anhand der wir Menschen beschreiben. Sagen das freundlicher Mensch oder ein unfreundlicher Mensch. Und es gibt nicht so etwas wie ein,
einen Menschen, von dem wir sagen, der ist freundlich,
Aber der verhält sich nicht so, ne? Also der, das ist eigentlich ein freundlicher Mensch, aber der ist die ganze Zeit unfreundlich, ne? Das also das ist eben die Idee, Eigenschaft als Verhaltensdisposition. Und jetzt gibt es natürlich eigentlich ein Universum an Verhalten, das unendlich ist,
Also du kannst ja immer alles Mögliche tun,
Und entsprechend mit dieser Definition Verhaltensdisposition würdest du auch automatisch aus jedem Verhalten.
Aus dem Universum, das möglich, das, aus dem unendlichen Universum des möglichen Verhaltens. Auch ein unendliches Universum aus möglichen Eigenschaften.
Definieren können. Wenn du rein bei dieser Verhaltensdisposition bleibst. Das heißt, ähm wir haben die gängigen Eigenschaften wie äh freundlich oder unfreundlich oder sowas, ne? Aber jetzt könnte man dir zum Beispiel sagen, du hast die Eigenschaft Podcaster,
weil.
Es treibt dich ans Mikrofon. Du machst das regelmäßig. Du hast die Verhaltensdisposition zu Podcasten und deswegen bist du ein Podcast, das stimmt ja auch. Ist ja richtig.
Ist fast dran. Kann man jetzt nicht so von der Hand weisen. Sagt aber nicht viel aus.
Jetzt könntest du zum Beispiel äh sagen.
Ähm vielleicht gibt es ja verschiedene Verhaltenstendenzen.
Also, Eigenschaften, die miteinander korrelieren. Zum Beispiel, dass man sagt, ähm äh du bist ähm.
Ähm du lachst oft, ja? Du triffst dich oft mit Leuten.
Du gehst auf Menschen zu, bist nicht schüchtern, ähm.
Und das wären ja alles Eigenschaften, die im Prinzip sehr nah beieinander sind, ja? Also Menschen, die äh auf andere zugehen und gesellig sind,
sind gleichzeitig nicht schüchtern. Ja und wer gesellig ist, geht auch gerne auf andere Leute zu und umgekehrt. Nicht immer, aber immer öfter. Also diese,
Eine Korrelation, das ist ja sowieso der Klassiker, dass Leute äh Korrelationen mit Korusalität vermischen, das hat man im Psychologiestudium immer sehr oft, wo dann die eigene Tante, aber als Gegenbeispiel für die
Die eigene Tante ist zufällig immer genau der Mensch, der gerade komplette psychologische Theorie ähm widerlegt,
Ähm aber es geht eben nicht darum, dass es bei jeder einzelnen Person deterministisch so ist, aber über die Masse der Menschen.
Mitte.
Dieser Idee, dass bestimmte Verhaltenstendenzen ja miteinander korrelieren, liegt der äh liegt,
Zugrunde das Konzept, dass es unter Umständen höher gestellte Grundeigenschaften der Persönlichkeit gibt.
Ähm die es uns ermöglichen, Personen einfacher und umfassender von einigen wenigen, durch einige wenige Eigenschaften zu beschreiben, als wenn wir jedes Mal ihr gesamtes Verhalten nehmen,
Ja, also du gehst quasi auf eine Meterebene.
Und ähm da gibt es ganz viele verschiedene Herangehensweisen das zu tun. Ähm, das eine war zum Beispiel Wörterbuch, du nimmst einfach die Eigenschaften.
Und sagst du, lässt Leute sagen, wie ähnlich ist diese Eigenschaft der Eigenschaft? Ja? Und dann guckst du irgendwann, ob sich so Cluster quasi bilden, ja, welche Eigenschaften irgendwo zusammenhängen.
Und diese Grundeigenschaften, die du haben willst, sollten dann wiederum möglichst unabhängig voneinander sein, weil also quasi Eigenschaft A sollte keine ähm keine Vorhersagekraft für Eigenschaft B haben,
weil sonst wäre ja die ne, würdest du sagen, die sind auf einer Dimension. Ja, wenn die.
Wenn die korrigiert sozusagen.
Dann würden die ja korrigieren, das heißt, du suchst nach nach nicht korrelierenden Grundeigenschaften,
oder Clusters von Eigenschaften, die wenig oder gar nicht miteinander korrelieren.
Also überschneidungsfreie Kategorien, nachdem man eine Person bewerte.
Genau. So und jetzt kannst du, das kannst du dann äh auf viele Weisen machen, also wie gesagt, du kannst die Wortbedeutung nehmen. Dann hast du so in, in
in welchen Dimensionen denken wir? Äh du kannst ganz viele verschiedene Fragebögen nehmen und diese Fragen miteinander korrigieren und dann stellst du irgendwann fest, okay ähm,
Leute, die hier ja sagen, sagen da nein. Ähm.
Die scheinen auf einer Dimension zu liegen und dann hast du immer mehr Fragen und dann kristallisieren sich egal wie du da dran gehst. Immer wieder fünf,
Dimensionen heraus,
die äh in der Persönlichkeitspsychologie bekannt sind als die Big Five. Und man könnte die Big Five beschreiben als quasi die fünf Dimensionen der Persönlichkeit,
Und diese fünf Dimensionen der Persönlichkeit sind,
wie folgt. Ich habe sie eigentlich immer in einer anderen Reihenfolge erklärt, äh als sie in diesem Artikel stehen, aber ich gehe sie mal, na ja, ich gehe sie in meiner äh.
In meiner Reihenfolge durch. Ähm Neurotizismus, Neurotizismus klingt natürlich jetzt total äh total schlimm, weil alle immer denken so, oh ja, Freud, Neurose und so, das ist alles, ne? Das Neurose ist was Schlimmes.
Ähm, die wenigsten Leute wissen wirklich, was eine, was eine Neurose ist. Aber was die Dimension Neurotizismus beschreibt, ist ähm die allgemeine,
Ängstlichkeit, Sorge, Verletzlichkeit, also Menschen ähm,
Ne, bist du von Sorge getrieben, hast du Angst, ne? Bist du irgendwie so oh vorsichtig hier, Kind nicht im Schmutz spielen lassen und wisch da lieber nochmal drüber und ich bin schon wieder krank, ich schone mich lieber. Also so dieses Getrieben von oder ihr beeinflusst von Angst und Sorge.
Oder bist du eher so, komm ist mir für dich äh völlig egal rein, äh gibt immer Verluste äh äh wo gehobelt wird.
Können alleine zur Schule gehen. Ja ja.
Ne? Also bist du bist du von Sorge getrieben, ein ein Sorge getriebener Mensch wäre höher auf der Neurotizismus-Skala,
heißt aber nicht direkt, dass er eine Neurose hat, also wenn man wenn Psychologe sagt, du bist so ein bisschen neurotisch, dann würden die Leute sofort sagen, oh mein Gott, was fällt dir ein, ne? Aber ist eine, eine, eine Dimension, auf der alle Menschen beschreibbar sind.
Was ist denn so der der übliche Werte äh das also die nee was wie bewertet man das? Also ist das so ja nein oder ist das von null bis zehn oder was?
Es gibt verschiedene ja guter Punkt, es gibt verschiedene ähm verschiedene Möglichkeiten, das zu erfassen. Klassische Möglichkeit ist ein Fragebogen. Ähm,
Es gibt verschiedene Fragebögen zur Erfassung der Big Five. Ich glaube so der, der einer der meist verbreiteten stellt so dreißig Fragen, von denen sind es dann im Prinzip fünf pro Dimensionen.
Und der Sport der Persönlichkeitspsychologie ist ähm mit so wenig Fragen wie möglich,
die Big Five so gut wie möglich zu beschreiben. Das ist ein wichtiger äh das ist ein wichtiger Punkt, auf den ich gleich nochmal zurückkomme. Ich würde nur gerne an dieser Stelle die äh die fünf Eigenschaftsdimensionen einmal noch kurz zu Ende erklären.
Aber ich könnte mir jetzt sozusagen jetzt, ich überlege jetzt gerade mal, wie ich mich hier so selber einschätze und könnte mir jetzt so ein eins bis fünf geben, so wenn ich jetzt irgendwie bei Norit Neurotizismus irgendwie eine Eins habe, dann bin ich so total in mir rund.
Äh es geht bei bei Datenanalyse ohnehin nicht um absolute Werte und ähm also ich habe,
bevorzugt mit Z standardisierten Werten zu arbeiten. Aber die wie du die Skala benennst, ist eigentlich völlig egal,
Also ob das jetzt von eins bis fünf oder von eins bis zehn geht äh ist äh ziemlich.
Ja okay, aber man kann ja sagen, also wenn ich jetzt total in mir ruhe, vollkommen selbstsicher, ohne Angst bin, so, dann bin ich so auf dem einen Ende der Skala und wenn ich so total verletzlicher, emotionaler äh ängstlicher Mensch bin, so, dann äh tendiere ich eher in die andere Richtung.
Ja und die Skala ist aber nicht an die Skala, also in der Psychologie sind Skalen nicht an ähm.
An unbedingt den vorstellbaren extremen orientiert,
sondern die sind an dem Durchschnitt der Menschen orientiert. Ja? Also das heißt äh der Nullpunkt von Neurotizismus ist nicht, dass du zu Hause sitzt und in dir ruhst.
Sondern wie alle anderen so.
Sondern der Nullpunkt ist, wie du, wie der durchschnittliche Mensch zu diesem Thema steht und dein Wert ist die Abweichung vom Durchschnitt,
Ja? Und üblicherweise arbeitest du mit Z standardisierten Werten, das heißt die Abweichung geteilt durch die Standardabweichung. Mit anderen Worten, du hast da einen Wert zwischen äh minus eins und eins.
In dem sich genau achtundsechzig Komma zwei Prozent der Gesamt äh Population befinden. Ähm beim IQ,
hat man sich überlegt, das wäre schlecht, wenn man dem Kind sagen müsste, dein IQ ist minus null Komma fünf. Ähm, was immer noch gut wäre, ne?
Der IT in IQ, ein IQ von minus null Komma fünf in Zwert wäre ein IQ von zweiundneunzig Komma fünf,
Äh denn IQ-Werte werden bei,
werden auf den, auf den Durchschnitt hundert normiert mit der Standardabweichung fünfzehn. Das heißt, achtundsechzig Komma zwei Prozent der Gesellschaft sind zwischen dem IQ fünfundachtzig und einhundertfünfzehn.
Ähm,
und beim IQ von einhundertdreißig bist du quasi zwei Standardabweichungen äh weg. Das heißt, da bist du in dem Bereich, wo du noch ganz, ganz wenige Leute hinkommen.
Und dann kommst du eben quasi in äh also man kann das quasi in in Prozentabweichung vom Durchschnitt sehen, aber das,
habe versucht das so ein bisschen zu umschiffen, weil das äh Methodenlehre ist äh immer sehr verwirrend, aber das Entscheidende ist, ne, wenn du einen IQ von neunzig hast, ähm heißt das, dass du, dass es dir so geht, wie ähm.
Vierunddreißig.
Prozent der Gesellschaft, die unterdurchschnittlich klug sind, aber immer noch durchschnittlich unterdurchschnittlich klug,
Ja, also das ist das ist der Begriff der Standardabweichung, ne? Du hast du definierst einen Mittelwert.
Dann nimmst du die durchschnittliche Abweichung von diesem Mittelwert. Ist übrigens auch sehr schön, wenn man ähm,
wenn man äh um mal jetzt mal die den Bereich der Psychologie zu verlassen, nimmst du ähm das durchschnittliche Einkommen, ja? Gehst du in Deutschland hin und sagst, was ist denn das durchschnittliche Haushaltseinkommen? Dann kriegst du irgend so einen Wert, wo der, wo der größere Teil der Leute sagen würde, wat,
Das kann aber ja irgendwie nicht sein. Und ein Mittelwert ist immer ähm völlig ähm.
Also der ist ja quasi der dieser Mittelwert ist ja irgendwo zwischen der Mittelschicht
der Einkommensmittelschicht, der Einkommensunterschicht und den wenigen Milliardären, ja? Und jetzt ist aber natürlich das Interessante, was wie du eigentlich eine Gesellschaft beschreiben möchtest, ist
von diesem Mittelwert, der ja irgendwo Abiträr, völlig egal, der ist ja nee, die ist in irgendeiner Währung ausgedrückt, die eine eine abitäre Einheit ist, völlig
ohne jegliche Aussage. Was über die Gesellschaft wirklich eine Aussage trifft ist von diesem Mittelwert, wie groß ist die durchschnittliche Abweichung.
Des einzelnen Haushaltes von diesem Wert. Also die Ungleichheit der Gesellschaft, das ist das, was wirklich interessant ist. Deswegen ist äh statistisch gesehen ähm kein einziger Wert,
jemals aussagekräftig ohne das Maß der Standardabweichung dazu, weil es im Prinzip quasi äh einen Wert ohne Skala wäre
ne? Und deswegen sind diese ähm äh Z-Werte eigentlich ganz schön, weil du sehen kannst, okay, wenn du zwischen minus eins und eins bist, bist du im durchschnittlichen Durchschnitt.
Äh so.
Kommen wir zurück zum Neuro.
Nee, wir kommen jetzt zur Extraversion. Ähm.
Genau, also wir hatten jetzt den.
Also Neurotizismus, allgemeine Ängstlichkeit.
Ich schreibe jetzt trotzdem mal auf, wie ich mich hier einschätze. Ist okay. Und eins bis fünf.
Extraversion. Mach mal, ist egal. Mach ohne Skala. Mal dir eine Mittellinie und mal dir das Striche rein. So wird es auch normalerweise dargestellt. Ähm extraversion.
Ähm Geselligkeit, ähm das aufeinander zugehen äh die äh also Extraversion äh ist quasi magst du es.
Mit,
Mit anderen Menschen zu kommunizieren und Dinge von dir preiszugeben. Also ein extravertierter Mensch ist ähm quasi, ne, der
Der redet viel, der lacht viel, der geht auf Leute zu, der genießt es im Mittelpunkt zu stehen, während der der introvertierte Mensch äh,
sich in der Personengruppe nicht so wohl fühlt, vielleicht ein bisschen eher seine Ruhe haben möchte, ähm sich gerne auch mal mit sich selber beschäftigt, ja? Man.
Zu allem, den man gleich eine Meinung haben muss.
Meinung ist noch eine andere Sache, aber der hat natürlich eine, aber der muss die vielleicht nicht die ganze Zeit mit allen.
Mitteilen, ja, genau.
Sondern der kann sich auch mal einen Tag äh in Ruhe alleine zu Hause beschäftigen und
schöpft daraus Energie während der der Extraversion der hohe Wert der Extraversion jemand ist der wenn er alleine zu Hause ist einfach auch nichts mit sich anzufangen. Das heißt es zieht ihn zu den Menschen ja,
Ähm,
So, das heißt, wir haben also Ängstlichkeit, Geselligkeit, um die jetzt mal in in etwas weniger äh fachspezifischen äh Begriffen zu nutzen. Äh dann haben wir die Verträglichkeit, also äh legst du Wert darauf,
Konflikte zu vermeiden. Ähm,
Kooperierst du? Bist du rücksichtsrücksichtsvoll gegenüber den anderen Menschen, ne? Oder sagst du, okay, komm,
Ich habe überhaupt gar keine Lust mit dir hier zu debattieren,
Ich habe jetzt meine Meinung und die wird jetzt durchgezogen, ja? Und äh ich weiß, dass das richtig ist und wenn ich dich davon nicht überzeugt bekomme, dann führe ich das auch gegen deinen Widerstand durch, weil ich weiß, dass dein Widerstand falsch ist,
Oder bis zu einem Punkt, dass du sagst, ich weiß zwar, dass dein Widerstand falsch ist, aber ich möchte ähm hier eine Lösung für alle anstreben,
Und ich bin verträglich. Ja, also ich mir, ich lege mehr Wert darauf, in der Gruppe Frieden zu haben.
Allen klar zu kommen.
Mit allen klar zu kommen, als das Richtige äh in meinen Augen Richtige zu tun, ja?
Kooperativ sein, freundlich sein, mitfühlen.
Verträglicher Mensch, also die die Begriffe sind ja dann auch, also bis jetzt auf Neurotizismus sind Extraversion. Auch eigentlich sehr naheliegende. Ja, so verträglicher Mensch leuchtet ein, ne,
fängte, kommt der rein, fängt die ganze Zeit Streit an. So und das das Spannende ist natürlich diese Verträglichkeit ist völlig unabhängig davon, ob du jetzt extravertiert äh oder oder introvertiert bist,
Und ähm ist auch völlig egal, ob du, ob du ängstlich bist oder nicht, ne? Du kannst verträglich sein äh und neurotisch oder eben nicht,
äh der der vierte ist ähm Gewissenhaftigkeit. Äh also.
Erledigst du die Dinge ordentlich und gründlich? Oder erlebst du die Dinge oberflächlich.
Ja? Ähm.
Auch das eigentlich ein Begriff, der sehr einleuchtend ist, ne? Also wenn du ein Mitarbeiter hast, ist der relativ schnell oder ein Kollegen äh ein Teammitglied oder so, dann weißt du, macht er die Dinge gewissenhaft, ja? Habe ich da noch zwanzig Rechtschreibfehler drin oder nicht?
Wenn die Wohnung äh gesaugt wurde, hat er auch oben überm Schrank äh gewischt,
ne? Äh hält er an der was weiß ich, kontrolliert den Reifendruck oder so, ne? Also äh das, was der Mensch tut, tut er,
ordentlich oder ist es so ein bisschen ach komm, hier passt schon irgendwie, ne.
Nachlässigkeit. Ähm und der letzte äh der der letzte im Bunde ist die die Offenheit gegenüber neuen Erfahrungen.
Ähm da wieder einer, der äh etwas äh missverständlich äh beschrieben ist, weil äh Offenheit für also Offenheit wird oft dann,
Psychologen verwechselt mit der Extraversion, ne? Aber ähm im Prinzip heißt das, wie aufgeschlossen du gegenüber neuem bist, was du noch nicht kennst.
Interessieren dich, interessiert,
dass Fremde und das Unbekannte? Oder bist du ähm zufrieden mit ähm mit dem, was du weißt und deinem Weltbild? Und brauchst du diese neuen Sachen nicht.
Brauchst du nicht diese Informationen, die nicht dazu passt. Interessieren dich diese Leute mit den Kopftüchern nicht, die jetzt auf einmal rumrennen, weil das war vorher besser.
Ähm,
Dieser Faktor wird häufig ein bisschen also wird gerne auch der Kulturfaktor genannt. Ähm und äh von anderen der Intelligenzfaktoren. Denn äh es ist diese, diese Eigenschaft Offenheit
gegenüber neuen Erfahrungen äh korreliert,
dem, was der, was äh was der IQ-Test auch äh auseinander äh was der EQ-Tipp äh EQ-Tipp. Der EQ-Test äh vorgibt zum Essen, der ähm,
Aber IQ-Test sind nochmal ein ganz anderes Thema, das klammern wir jetzt hier mal aus. Also Offenheit gegenüber neuen Erfahrungen. So und jetzt kannst du dir quasi ein,
Jeden mit diesem Muster kannst du quasi so einen Schnelltest machen.
Über Menschen und sagst okay, hier ist ein Mensch, ich ordne den ein, neurotisch, ja mehr oder weniger. Extravertiert, ja, mehr oder weniger,
Verträglich? Mehr oder weniger,
Gewissenhaftigkeit, mehr oder weniger und Offenheit gegenüber neuen Erfahrungen. So und die Theorie ist, dass
dass die fünf Meter Eigenschaften des Menschen sind
Ne? Sie sagen nicht ein kein konkrete weitere Eigenschaft vorher. Sie sagen auch nicht bestimmt konkretes Verhalten vorher. Aber sie sind das Beste,
wie man einen Menschen schnell und.
Also so schnell wie möglich, so genauso genau wie möglich uns so umfangreich wie möglich beschreiben kann. Denn wenn es,
Eigenschaften gäbe, die außerhalb der Big Five liegen. Ähm
legen, dann gäbe es ja Big Six oder Big Four, ja? Die einzelne konkrete Manifistation einer Eigenschaft, kann aber natürlich auch quer
zu diesen Dimensionen liegen, ne? Also diese Dimensionen sind ja jetzt fünf, die korrigieren teilweise minimal auch miteinander. Ähm aber die die das theoretische Modell ist, du hast im Prinzip einen fünfdimensionalen Raum
In dem diese Skalen alle diese Dimensionen, alle orthokonal zueinander sind
und jede Persönlichkeit ist in diesem Raum anordnbar und jede Eigenschaft ist ähm in diesem Raum auch beschreibbar, ja? Das heißt zum also und und kann eben Kombination sein, ne? Also jemand, der,
Extra wird hier äh extravertiert und verträglich ist, ne? Da hätten haben wir wahrscheinlich ein weiteres Wort für, fällt mir jetzt gerade nicht ein, aber da haben wir dann eine Eigenschaft, die wir auch benennen in unserem Denken.
Hier war eigentlich eine Mischung aus zwei Farben.
Eine Mischung aus, die eine Mischung auf zwei Dimensionen ist.
Also so wie es so im im sichtbaren Licht so die drei Grundfarben gibt, gibt's halt hier so fünf äh Grundfarben und die Persönlichkeit des einzelnen mischt sich halt aus äh unterschiedlichen.
Genau. Farbe ist ein super Vergleich, den wir in Jahren nicht äh äh so als Idee gekommen ist,
Aber wenn man sagt halt hier, ne? Äh genau, es gibt Grundfarben und es gibt eine ganze und es gibt einen ganzen Regenbogen, ne.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Millionen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Millionen Farben heute Displays darstellen können, anhand von eigentlich drei Grundfarben.
Aber das Passwort, was jetzt hier äh eingeführt wird, ist äh das Wasser, genauer der Ocean, weil wenn man jetzt diese fünf Kategorien nimmt. Concentiusness. Ähm ist ja immer.
New Rot ist ähm.
Real Business.
Ja, so, also das ist lange hergeleitet, das ist im Prinzip sowas wie das das allgemeine Modell der der Persönlichkeit, so so wird Persönlichkeit erfasst. So und jetzt kommt der, jetzt.
Sind natürlich alle gespannt wie wir jetzt den Bogen zur Netzpolitik kriegen.
Da will ich ja gerade drauf. So, jetzt hast du gefragt, jetzt hast du gefragt, wie ähm wie wird das erfasst, ne? Also diese Idee, dass es das.
Ja, wo wo kriegt man jetzt diese ganzen Daten her? Du hast ja gesagt,
Ja, ich frage jetzt bloß nochmal explizit nach so, ne? Also das ist ja sozusagen die Frage, wie kriegt man sozusagen so ein umfassendes Bild. Gerade wenn auch alles miteinander korrigiert und die Aussagen ja überhaupt erst nur dann greifen, wenn auch äh alle mehr oder weniger vergleichbar gefragt werden,
äh dann muss er diese Daten auch erstmal irgendwo herholen. Das heißt normalerweise hat man dann Leute wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Fragebogen ausfüllen lassen.
Genau, also ursprünglich die Entwicklung der Idee war so, dass man irgendwann mal äh wie gesagt, mit Eigenschaftswörtern festgestellt hat, oh guck mal.
Nach einer statistischen Analyse stellen wir bestimmte Cluster von Eigenschaften fest und da scheint es irgendwie was zu geben. Also irgendwann hat sich das immer mehr herauskristallisiert, dass man diese Big Five immer findet, ja? Äh die Frage ist übrigens auch bis,
viele, entschuldigung, ganz kurz. Es ist auch eher eine philosophische, ist, sind das die ähm,
sind das wirklich die Grunddimensionen von Eigenschaften, von Persönlichkeit? Oder sind das einfach die Grunddimensionen von dem, wie wir über Persönlichkeit und Eigenschaften reden,
ja? Deswegen auch die beiden Herangehensweisen einmal, dass man das lexikalisch gefunden hat und dann gleichzeitig wieder im Verhaltensbeschreibenden, ja? So,
Dann sind die sind die Forscher hingegangen.
Eine kurze Nachfrage noch. Wie wie etabliert ist dieses Modell in der Psycholo.
Nicht mehr zur Frage. Steht nicht mehr zur.
Zu sagen wirklich so eine Grunderkennung.
Will ich ja gerade hinaus, das. So und dann sind die Leute hingekommen und haben gesagt, es gibt im Prinzip, es ist keinem gelungen, andere Big Five zu finden. Oder zu sagen, es gibt nur Big Four oder es gibt Big Big Six, ja? Ähm.
Es gibt dann noch irgendwelche, also dann gibt's da so
esoterische Modelle, irgendwie Meier, Brix, haste nicht gesehen, Typen, Fragebogen, ja, der übrigens auch, glaube ich, zwei davon den Big Five irgendwie auch drin hat, so ne. Es gibt allen möglichen Kram, aber das Entscheidende ist,
Modelle in der in der in Wissenschaft und in in der Psychologie natürlich auch bewertest du ja daran erklären sie
dein Forschungsgegenstand möglichst allumfassend und erklären sie ihnen ökonomisch.
Und da ist eben ganz klar, dass äh dass du bei allem, was du an Verhalten findest, du es auf dieser in auf diesem Big Five anordnen kannst.
Und das heißt, die sind zumindest schon mal ein gutes Modell der der dessen, was Persönlichkeit ist,
Aber wie gesagt das eigentliche Verhalten kann sich dann wieder in ganz ganz vielen Ausprägungen zeigen und hat ist sehr distant von diesem Metamodell der Eigenschaften.
Pass auf vielleicht nochmal ein Beispiel liefern, wo sich dieses Modell auch mal so bewährt hat, also wo worum isst man sich so sicher, dass das sozusagen so gut trifft
nur weil jetzt keinmal bis eingefallen ist oder kann man, gibt's sozusagen Untersuchungen, wo man gesagt so, ah, so haben wir jetzt mal diese Gruppe analysiert und da haben wir jetzt auch.
Naja, da da kommst du wieder in den in den, in den, in den letztendlich, in den Zirkelschluss der Wissenschaft ist, weil,
wenn du sagst, Psychologie ist die Wissenschaft vom Erklären, Beschreiben erklären und Vorhersagen von Verhalten. So ist glaube ich die Definition äh.
Und du kannst das mit deinem Modell sehr gut machen.
Und dein Modell ist genügt, genügt darüber hinaus, den wissenschaftlichen Kriterien, das ist nämlich auf, falls ihr fixierbar ist. Ist ja der Klassiker, ne? Nicht fallsifizierbare Theorien aufstellen und dann nachher sagen, ist, kennen wir. Ähm.
Dann musst du ja im Prinzip,
Die ganze Zeit nach Dingen suchen, die dieses Modell wiederlegen. Und es ist inzwischen ähm in der Psychologie unstrittig, dass dieses Modell ein sehr gutes.
Sehr umfassendes und sehr vorhersagekräftiges Erfassen von Persönlichkeit
ermöglicht. Das heißt nicht, dass wir in uns fünf Werte haben und alle Menschen nur in fünf Werten in fünf Dimensionen funktionieren und das,
dass wir den ganzen Menschen auf fünf fünf Werte reduzieren? Nein.
Das ist eine fünfdimensionale Betrachtung einer bestimmten Gruppe.
Genau und vor allem das Verhalten der das die äh,
Die Unendlichkeit des Verhaltens bleibt ja trotzdem da. Wir stellen nur Koordination zwischen Verhaltenstendenzen fest und wir erkennen Farben von Verhaltensweisen und können sagen, na ja, wenn du das machst, wenn du ähm,
Base Jumping. Als Hobbyhass, dann ist es unwahrscheinlich, dass du hohe Werte auf der Neurotiz neurotizismusgala hast,
Aber wir können nicht sagen, du hast niedrige Werte auf der äh Neurotizismus-Skala. Du bist ein Basejumper.
Ja. Ja. Also mhm.
Ne? Also das ist auch ein gängiger, gängige Misskonzeption. So, das heißt.
In der Persönlichkeitspsychologie stehen steht den Big Five äh
glaube ich, die stellt keiner mehr nennenswert in Frage, als ein ökonomisches, gutes Modell zu einer umfassenden Beschreibung von Persönlichkeit. Er umfassenden Erfassung von Persönlichkeit. So. Ähm dann ist aber natürlich der Sport,
wie erfasst du die Big Five möglichst präzise.
Ökonomisch. Also ich hatte gerade diesen Fragebogen genannt mit mit dreißig Fragen, ja? Äh äh oder fünfundzwanzig oder wie auch immer, ja? Ähm.
Der Sport wäre und wir gehen ja davon aus, äh als Wissenschaftler, das ist ein,
Waren Wert gibt. Der schlummert in dir. Den können wir aber nicht erfassen, ne? Wenn ich dich jetzt, wenn ich dich jetzt frage, Tim, äh wie ähm,
Wie ängstlich bist du und du sagst jetzt fünf, ne? Dann kenne ich deine Skala nicht, ich kenne nicht die Vergleichswerte, also du kannst diesen du kannst diesen wahren Wert nicht verraten.
Man müsste mich eigentlich dabei beobachten, wo ich dieses Verhalten tatsächlich an den Tag le.
Ich brauche Messwerte. Und jetzt hast du natürlich in der Psychologie relativ viele verschiedene Möglichkeiten zu messen. Ich könnte dich beobachten,
ich könnte deine Freunde fragen, ich könnte dich selber fragen, ne? Also Selbstauskunft, Fragebogen,
So, dann stellst du, kriegst du diese ganzen Fragen. Dann schrei da sind da so Dinge drin und so. Manchmal äh kann ich abends nicht einschlafen, weil ich mir Sorgen über Dinge mache. Na ja, kennst du, ah ja, okay. Das ist eine Frage nach Neurotizismus, ja? Oder ich gehe gerne äh.
Ich genieße es einen Abend in geselliger Runde zu verbringen. Ah klar, Extraversion, ne? Und dann irgendwie so, ich interessiere mich für die, für das kulturelle Leben in der Stadt, in der ich wohne. Ah, Offenheit
für neue Erfahrungen, ja? Also wenn ich mit einer Person Streit habe, dann äh lässt mir das keine Ruhe Verträglichkeit, ja? Solche Fragen stellst du den Leuten dann? Und er rechnest
Guckst dann, hast du eben an? Ja, nein, Antworten, machst du ein bisschen statische Analyse und dann hast du so einen äh hast du halt deine fünf Werte. So
Jetzt kommt der Sport der Persönlichkeitspsychologie. Es ist ganz klar, je mehr ähm.
Je mehr du die Leute fragst, je mehr Fragen du die beantworten lässt, je länger du die beobachtest, desto genauer wird deine Vorhersage, ja? Eine weitere Frage kann immer nur meine Vorhersagegenauigkeit,
allgemein verbessern. Vielleicht nicht auf die eine Person, aber auf die Gesamtheit der Person, die ich frage. Ähm,
Aber das heißt natürlich der Sport unter den Psychologen ist mit so wenig wie möglich diese Eigenschaften vorherzusagen.
Damit zu wenig Daten.
Mit so wenig,
Erhebungen wie wie möglich. Mit so wenig Aufwand wie möglich, ne? Dieser Fragebogen mit den, was weiß ich, dreißig oder fünfundzwanzig Fragen ähm ist,
dir vielleicht zu viel, ja? Ich kann das Gleiche machen mit fünf Fragen,
Kriege aber wahrscheinlich nicht so genaue Werte. Jetzt ist die Frage, was ist genau? Ähm genau ist immer das, was Verhalten vorhersagt, was äh oder was eben ein Fremdurteil vorhersagt. Ähm also ne, wie gesagt, Selbstauskunft äh Verhaltensbeobachtung oder,
Urteil deiner Freude, die ich fragen kann, ist der Tim verträglich oder nicht?
Oder Überwachung.
Oder Überwachung. So, jetzt kommt der, jetzt kommen wir der Sache näher in diesem, in diesem Magazinartikel wird so ein bisschen gesagt, dass der äh Herr Kosinski, der da porträtiert wird, äh mehr oder weniger das das alles sich ausgedacht hätte. Ähm da,
täuschte mich dann meine äh,
mein Eindruck nicht, also es ist für ihn jetzt nicht absprechen, dass er sich das alles ausgedacht hat. Aber der ist offenbar ein führender Experte für Psychometrik
ist das aber auch erst nach meiner Zeit geworden, denn so die Veröffentlichung von dem finde ich irgendwie dann so ab zwanzig zwölf oder so. Die ersten Forschungen, die ich so zu Facebook
und und den Big Five gefunden habe ähm
oder an die ich mich erinnere, da gibt's sicherlich noch anderes, aber die bekannten Studien, die häufig zitiert werden, sind äh von äh Samir Gosling und äh Media Back,
die ich zufälligerweise kenne. Ähm, die sich mit mit so Facebook-Profilen und so auseinandergesetzt haben. Also ganz ganz viel machen,
Na Christian, zum Beispiel so raus, okay? Du gibst nimmst einen Fremdenbegutachter, zeigst dem ein Facebook-Profil.
Und sagst dem, jetzt nimm mal hier diese Big Five und sag mal, was du glaubst, welche Werte diese Person da.
Ist das eine ängstliche Person, äh hier Base Jumper und so weiter, genau. Die Sachen, die wir eben hatten.
Und stellt sich raus, die unterschiedlichen Eigenschaften ähm,
Dimensionen lassen sich anhand des so eines Facebook-Profils den einen Eindruck, den ein Mensch da hat, äh, unterschiedlich gut vorhersagen, ja? Also so zum Beispiel sowas wie Extraversion kriegst du super leicht,
weil wir da auch Ques haben als Mensch, ne? Guckst du im Facebook-Profil an, da ist irgendwie so ein lachender Mensch, umarmt im Tanz mit seinen Freunden, dann sagt er, ja, extravertiert, ne? Wie gewissenhaft der ist, erkennst du dann vielleicht,
Als Q daran, ob der den oberen Knopf am Hemd zu hat oder nicht oder ob der irgendwie noch ein Eigelb auf dem äh auf eine Bluse hängen hat oder oder ne?
Aber wie äh wie also Offenheit für neue Erfahrung erkennst du nicht so leicht, weil es auch so ein bisschen diffuserer Faktor ist und so. Da gibt's also sehr viel Forschung.
Ähm und das Spannende ist eigentlich immer, dass so so einfach wie so schnell wie möglich anhand von allem herauszufinden, dass das machen,
äh Persönlichkeitspsychologen, ja? Die,
kümmern sich entweder um spezifische Eigenschaften oder spezifische Probleme oder die Passung von Eigenschaften unter Untermenschen, also Beziehungspsychologie oder so oder sie machen sich einen Sport daraus, sich irgendeine Datenquelle zu nehmen und daraus möglichst die Big Five Feuer zu sagen,
Und genau das hat dieser äh das hat dieser äh Herr äh Kosinski die letzten Jahre wohl erforscht, nämlich ähm.
Und die Leute einmal so ein, so ein Facebook über Facebook so einen Fragebogen ausfüllen lassen, wo sie dann ihre Big Five zurückbekommen haben,
ja, dann wurde ihnen gesagt, hier du hast jetzt unseren Big Five Fragebogen beantwortet. Das ist dein Ergebnis. Jetzt kannst du hast hier einen Grafen, jetzt kannst du dich mit deinen Freunden vergleichen oder so. Hast du ein bisschen was über dich gelernt? Ist so
Hauptmotivation, warum Menschen an äh psychologischen Studien teilnehmen ist, dass sie ein Feedback darüber bekommen,
Gleichzeitig haben diese ähm haben.
Haben sie dann aber deinen quasi Zugriff auf dein Facebook-Profil und können dein weiteres Verhalten sehen und können dann zum Beispiel äh deine ähm deine äh Likes.
Auswerten, ja?
Oder auch deine Posts.
Oder deine Posts und bald über die Posts, da hast du Inhalte, da kannst du dann Zentimeter Analyses machen, dann siehst du verwendet
Dieser Mensch fröhliche oder negative Worte, ja? Wenn der, wenn der, wenn die ganze Zeit über Sorge schreibt und irgendwie Angst und
und und irgendwie traurige Smileys macht, dann hat das im Zweifelsfall mit Neurotizismus zu tun, ja? Mit der Neurotizismus-Gala. Ähm, wenn er die ganz äh ne
wenn er die ganze Zeit von irgendwelchen kulturellen Events postet, dann sind wir wieder bei dieser Open Mist zur Experience. Also man sieht dieses Modell ist relativ intuitiv recht tragfähig.
Und ähm das haben die halt gemacht und zwar über Jahre. Äh im Prinzip sich angeschaut, wie können wir die Datenbasis, die Facebook bereitstellt, also Likes und so weiter. Ähm.
In in Verbindung bringen zu den Big Five. Jetzt wird hier in dem Artikel genannt. Zum Beispiel sind Männer, die die Kosmetikmarke Mac liken mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit schwul,
Äh
Wie gesagt, das entscheidet, hier ist wieder ein bisschen Wissenschaftssprech, ne? Mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit, das heißt, nicht alle, die Mac liken, sind schwul, aber unter denen die Mac liken, äh stellen wir eine
erhöhte
Prävalenz, nee, also Prävalenz sagt der Psychologe, da ist aber ein schlechter Begriff, weil Prävalenz auch bei Krankheiten äh genutzt wird von Ärzten. Deswegen ist das ein schlechtes Wort. Aber sagen wir einen höheren Anteil,
homosexueller als wir bei anderen Sachen haben,
bei irgendwie so und schönes Beispiel, was hier auch später kommt ist ähm ein gute Vorhersage von Trump ähm.
Von von Trump Fentom,
ja? Ist das Liken von amerikanischen Autos? Das hat ein bisschen was zu tun äh mit, also es ist seit Jahrzehnten so ein
Thema in den USA, denen ist ja die Autoindustrie äh aufgrund mangelnder Qualität mehr oder weniger abgeschmiert und ähm da wurde es dann immer so als das als äh der Verrat am eigenen Land betrachteten Toyota zu fahren, ne? Bei American und so, ne
Ähm übrigens genau, da sind wir auch ein bis.
Japaner.
Kauf nicht beim beim Japaner und so weiter, dann sind wir genau bei diesem Globalisierungskritik und so weiter, ne? Deswegen ist es auch nicht überraschend,
dass sich dadurch eine eine die Trampählerschaft unter anderem dadurch erkennen lässt, dass sie sich für amerikanische Autos interessiert.
Nicht jeder, der ein amerikanisches Auto fährt, will Trump.
Aber unter denen, die ein amerikanisches Auto fahren, hast du mehr Trump-Fehler als in der allgemeinen äh als in der Allgemeinpopulation.
Ähm und das ne, das ist hier in dem Artikel auch korrekt beschrieben, wie gut ein Modell ist, zeigt sich daran, wie gut es vorhersagen kann, wie eine Testperson auf bestimmte Fragen bean.
Wird. Ähm, das heißt was du im Prinzip machst ist du hast.
Einmal diesen Big Five Fragebogen gemacht. Äh du kennst quasi das Beste,
die besten Ergebnisse, die du hast und dann setzt du, weil du ja nicht immer nur du hast ja diese ganze Analyse, machst du immer über mehrere Personen, nicht über einen. So und dann hast du deine Gesamtpopulation an Menschen, paar hunderttausend, von jedem hast du die Big Five und dann kommt irgendein Link ins Internet.
Ähm keine Ahnung, Hillary Clinton ist äh hier Kinderporno-Ring oder so. So dann hast du irgendwie dann dann,
guckst du einfach von all deinen Leuten, die du da in deiner Versuchspersonengruppe hast.
Betriggert das.
Wer klickt das an? Wen triggert das? Wer liket das? Und dann guckst du dir die Durchschnittlichen, das das durchschnittliche Big Five Profil an, von den Leuten, die das geklickt haben und vergleichst das mit,
Big Five Profil, was du in der Grund gesamtheit hast. Das Big Five Propil Profil der Grundgesamtheit sollte natürlich eigentlich eine gerade Linie sein, weil sonst ist deine Stichprobe verzerrt, aber,
methodische Finesse. Das Entscheidende ist, du kannst dann erkennen ah äh die Leute, die,
extra die Extraversion hohe Extraversionswerte haben, interessieren sich für das hier, ja? Oder dann stellst du eben fest, na ja ähm
Unter den Leuten, die hier Mac anklicken, sind erstmal äh neunzig Prozent weiblich und zehn Prozent männlich. Also scheint das ein Thema zu sein, was
feminine Personen mehr interessiert als äh als äh männliche Person und dann stellst du fest, na ja und von den männlichen Personen ist auch noch dann ein größerer Teil äh homosexuell als sonst,
Und dann hast du so eine Einordnung, ne? Und das kannst du natürlich mit allen möglichen Scheiß machen. Kannst jetzt mit Fake News machen und dann erkennst du, ah okay, mit auf den,
auf dem Big Five niedriger Wert bei Open Nis to Experience, äh also dem Kultur und Intelligenzfaktor äh sagt vorher, dass du eher diese Fake News likest, weil du weniger kritisch bist, ähm.
Weniger Intelligent, äh vielleicht äh und äh oder sowas, ne? Wer jetzt so so Hypothesen, aber so das ist so die, die ähm,
das Modell dahinter. So und das.
Mhm. Und genau und diese diese konkrete Verwendung von Facebook für diese Psychometrie.
Das hat jetzt dieser Kosinski gemacht.
Sei er halt ein toller Hecht. Ich hatte von den Menschen vorher noch nie was gehört und dann hat er irgen.
Forschung und sind längere Zeit nicht mehr so, aber das ist genau das. So und jetzt jetzt kommen wir zu seinen Ergebnissen. Das ist nämlich das wirklich Spannende. Ähm,
So, hier wird ein bisschen zitiert äh,
Kosinsky und sein Team verfeinern die Modelle unablässig. Klar, wenn du einmal so eine lebende Stichprobe hast, die dir immer wieder neue Daten äh füttert, so dadurch, dass die Leute die ganze Zeit irgendwas liken. Machst du dein Modell immer besser, immer genauer, ne?
Ähm.
Mehr Pixel.
Immer mehr, du, du klärst immer mehr Varianz auf und auch immer mehr Facetten und du trennst dich natürlich auch sofort wieder von diesem Big Five und machst dann mach's,
wieder eigene, genauere ähm ähm Kategorien von Eigenschaften aus, die du suchst, ne? Nicht alle Persönlichkeitspsychologie, setzt sich ja mit dem mit dem, mit dem großen Ding auseinander. Häufig wird's ja ganz konkretes Verhalten wissen
zum Beispiel will Trump oder nicht,
dann nimmst du jetzt nicht deine, dann nimmst du ja nicht die die Big Five, sondern du guckst halt spezifisch, wofür interessieren sich Trump-Wähler, ne? Dann wirst du wieder feingliedriger,
So und jetzt sagt er zweitausendzwölf er bringt äh Kosinski den Nachweis, dass man aus durchschnittlich
achtundsechzig Facebook Likes eines Users vorhersagen kann, welche Hautfarbe er hat. Fünfundneunzigprozentige Treffsicherheit ist immer das Ding, du, also ab
Fünf Prozent Fehler wahrscheinlich mit bis zu fünf Prozent Fehlerwahrscheinlichkeit tolerierst du das als ein vorhersagendes Ding. Ne? Also sagt ich brauche im Durchschnitt achtundsechzig Facebook Likes von dir ähm um,
Um zu wissen, welche Hautfarbe du hast. So,
Ein Fremdbeobachter müsste nur einmal hingucken und im Fragebogen müsste ich dir auch nur eine Frage stellen. Die achtundsechzig Likes lieferst du mir aber innerhalb von sagen wir mal zwei Tagen.
Und zwar freiwillig ohne dass ich dafür irgendwas machen musste. Und die kann ich auch noch zur Vorhersage von vielen anderen Dingen nutzen. Ja?
Das ist also so, äh das ist also im Prinzip das, was sich da dahinter verbirgt. Das Gleiche, ob er äh homosexuell ist, achtundachtzig prozentige Wahrscheinlichkeit, na ja, wie gesagt, eigentlich äh nicht nicht,
nicht besonders gut, aber natürlich immerhin nochmal besser, ne? Weil die Frage also Vorhersagewahrscheinlichkeit äh ist auch nicht gleichbedeutend mit dem Gewicht einer Korrelation und so weiter. Ich will ein bisschen mit Tonlehre rauslassen,
Ob er Demokrat oder Republikaner ist, fünfundachtzigprozentige Vorhersagewahrscheinlichkeit. Aber es geht noch weiter. Intelligenz, Religion, Religionszugehörigkeit, Alkohol, Zigaretten, Drogenkonsum lassen sich berechnen. Wie gesagt
Vorhersage in der Psychologie immer auf die Menge der Leute, nicht auf die Einzelperson. Ähm,
sogar, ob die Eltern einer Person bis zu deren einundzwanzigsten Lebensjahr zusammengeblieben sind oder nicht. Also wir kommen hier wieder von dem Big Five weg, ne? Zu den spezifischen Verhaltensweisen, für die sich Persönlichkeitspsychologen interessieren.
Und dann die Vorhersagekraft, die eben so ein ausreichend großer Datensatz wie Facebook ihn hat. Äh eben ermöglicht.
Und äh genau, äh wie gut ein Modell ist, zeigt sich daran, wie gut es vorher sagen kann, wie eine Testperson bestimmte Fragen beantworten wird, beziehungsweise wie sie bestimmtes Verhalten zeigen wird. Ähm,
Bald kann sein Modell anhand von zehn Facebook Likes eine Person besser einschätzen als ein durchschnittlicher Arbeitskollege
Äh das ist eine relativ unzulässige Verkürzung, weil wie gut der Arbeitskollege das Verhalten einschätzt, ist wieder so eine Frage. Du weißt ja gar nicht genau, was richtig ist, aber sagen wir mal so, man erkennt das Modell wird besser
Äh siebzig Likes reichen um die Menschenkenntnis eines Freundes zu überbieten, hundertfünfzig, um die der Eltern,
mit dreihundert Likes kann die Maschine das Verhalten einer Person eindeutiger vorhersagen als deren Partner. Das ist spannend,
Verhaltensvorhersage, ja? Das ist das Spannende, dieser anderen, ich könnte dich besser als deine Eltern, das ist äh sind ähm mathematische oder statistische Werte, die
unter Umständen nicht so wirklich genau äh
das sagen, was da steht. Aber mit dreihundert Likes kann ich das Verhalten einer Person eindeutiger vorhersagen, als deren Partner. Das ist entscheidend,
Das ist relevant. So, jetzt musst du überlegen, wie lange brauchst du um dreihundert Likes äh irgendwie im Internet zu verteilen? Dazu gibt's noch die Datenquellen, die du eh schon ausgefüllt hast. Dazu gibt's noch äh vielleicht weitere Analysen, zum Beispiel dessen, was du schreibst und so.
Wie viel Likes hast du schon so verteilt in deinem Leben.
Ich gar keinen einzigen, ich äh habe keine Facebook, aber bei Twitter wahrscheinlich irgendwie schon ein paar, ne? Und ähm,
Und jetzt steht da wird dieser Artikel halt wieder so ein bisschen unsauber. Mit noch mehr Likes lässt sich sogar übertreffen, was Menschen von sich selber zu wissen glauben. Ja, das ist halt ähm also das ist so ein bisschen sorry, also das ist äh,
nicht zulässig dieser dieser äh dieser Schluss, also das ist äh sehr verkürzt von äh von mathematischen und und und sonstigen Modellen. Aber okay.
Die vorhersagbarkeit wächst deutlich an. Das ist das glaube ich, was.
Genau, die Vorhersagebarkeit wächst eindeutig an. So, am Tag als äh Kosinsky diese Erkenntnisse publiziert, erhält er zwei Anrufe.
Eine Klageandrohung und ein Stellenangebot.
Facebook. Und genau das ist natürlich das, was Facebook immer gemacht hat. Das ist genau das, was ist all das, was hier jetzt in diesem Artikel steht, ist die einzige Idee dessen, was Facebook jemals war,
die Menschen genauso zu erfassen.
Ähm und das für Werbung zu nutzen, ja? Äh Facebook ist deshalb ökonomisch erfolgreich, weil sie Werbetreibenden die beste äh Conversionrate bieten,
ja? Die die sagen, wenn du auf Facebook wirbst, dann kriegst du das Beste für dein Geld. Nämlich, dass die Leute die Scheiße kaufen.
Und zwar nach deinen, nach deinen Maßgaben. Facebook hatte äh massive Kritik übrigens äh ähm die die haben bei diesem Targeting in der Werbung konntest du sagen, willst du weiß oder schwarze Tage?
Ihr so Nase und das haben die äh also das ist natürlich schon ein bisschen grenzwertig, weil ja ähm
Hautfarbe ähm gesellschaftlich eine Dimension ist, die wir für nicht relevant haben wollen. Wir wollen nicht, dass es eine Rolle spielt. Tut es aber überall,
ja? Und deswegen bietet Facebook das auch an,
Deswegen nutzen die Leute das auch, ja? Weil es für unter deren Maßgabe richtig ist, so Witz hier, du willst Make-up vermieten, äh, verkaufen? Warum solltest du dein Make-up für hellhäutige,
dunkelhäutige Marketen und umgekehrt
also kann, haben wir hier eine Checkbox. Kannst die Hautfarbe der Leute aussuchen, kannst die Sexualität der Leute aussuchen, kannst dir alles aussuchen
wir sorgen dafür, dass du die Einblendung bei den Leuten kriegst, die die Scheiße am Ende kaufen und wir sorgen dafür, dass sie das entsprechend klicken und deswegen sind wir auch besser als jeder andere, weil wir mehr wissen
über diese Leute zu denen du Werbung trägst als jeder andere und deswegen sind wir ein Milliardenunternehmen,
Aus keinem anderen Grund. Jetzt kommt ganz völlig schockierend, auf einmal die Erkenntnis, ja, nach Jahrzehnten
oder äh ich weiß nicht, seit wann es Facebook gibt, aber über ein Jahrzehnt auf jeden Fall, ne? Also wenn äh Gosling und und back irgendwie zweitausendsieben zum ersten Mal zu Facebook publiziert haben. Ich weiß, dass Facebook gibt's wahrscheinlich seit zweitausen,
Eins oder was? Ich weiß es nicht, seit wann es Facebook gibt.
Ähm ich schaue gerade mal nach, zweitausendvier. Zweitausendvier. Zwölf Jahre.
Zweitausendvier. Krass, genauso lange wie Netzpolitik Ork. Zufall?
Ne. Das war das war vorher, sage ich, war so. Du bist vom.
Ähm na aber das war das war das war alles was Facebook jemals ausgemacht hat. Das war übrigens auch der Grund warum irgendwann mal äh dieser Holzbringverlag hundert Millionen bezahlt hat. Für Studi VZ. Na ja, er hat sich dann herausgestellt, war doch nicht so gut.
Wie auch die ganzen anderen Dinge, die sie gekauft haben.
So und jetzt kommt plötzlich natürlich jemand auf die Idee, fucking hell, ja, was jeden Tag die ganze Zeit dafür benutzt wird, äh uns irgendeine Scheiße anzudrehen, die wir nicht haben wollen,
Ähm da ähm könnte man ja auch mal äh im Rahmen von Wahlen,
nutzen. Und das hat natürlich haben, hier wird's jetzt nur mit Trump äh dargestellt und hier wird auch der Brexit dann als Thema genannt. Es gibt nämlich ein Unternehmen mit dem vier mit dem Namen,
Äh Strete Communications, Levertories ähm,
bewirbt sich selber als eine weltweit agierende Wahlmanagementagentur.
Ähm sie bieten Marketing auf Basis eines psychologischen Modelles. Schwerpunkt,
Wahlbeeinflussung, also Wahlbeeinflussung ist auch so ein großes Wort, ne? Ich glaube, wir haben in der letzten Sendung schon gesagt, jede Zeitung äh will die Wahl beeinflussen,
Äh wir, jedes politische Handeln ist letztendlich darauf ausgelegt, dass hoffentlich Menschen was anderes wählen. Oder vieles politischer Handeln. Ähm.
So.
Oder es nicht wählen.
Oder nicht wählen, ja? Da waren wir in der letzten Sendung drüber gesprochen, ne? Aber hinter äh SCL verbirgt sich ein kompliziertes Firmenkonstrukt mit Ablegern in Steuerparadiesen
die auch in den Panama-Papers und in Wiki Leaks Enthüllung auftauchen
Manche von diesen Firmen haben bei Umstürzen in den Entwicklungsländern mitgewirkt, andere entwickeln für die NATO-Methoden zur psychologischen Manipulation der Bevölkerung
in Afghanistan. All das steht jetzt hier in diesem Artikel ohne weiteren Beleg, ja? Nehmen wir einfach mal so zur Kenntnis. Entscheidend ist, hier ist eine Firma hingegangen und hat gesagt, na ja, diese ganze
diese ganze Datenreichtum der, der uns durch die sozialen Netzwerke zur Verfügung gestellt wird, den nutzen wir doch mal. So und äh ähm,
Jetzt machen wir hier einen auf Big Data und äh wir wissen relativ viel über diese Leute. Und jetzt ist aber die Frage, was machst du damit? Und in diesem Artikel wird jetzt weiterhin der ähm.
Die die äh der nicht ganz zulässige Schluss äh.
Nahegelegt, nicht explizit, aber dass sie anhand der Big Five und anhand der Forschung von diesem Kosinski am Ende dazu dafür gesorgt haben, dass der Trump gewählt wurde. Was sie gemacht haben, ist, dass sie natürlich ein,
Ne, wenn du jetzt überlegst, du startest das, was ich hier in ein paar Minuten erklären kann, nachdem ich ein paar Jahre äh Psychologie gemacht habe. Oder nach der, eigentlich kannst du das erklären.
Nachdem er irgendwie zwei, zwei Vorlesungen Persönlichkeitspsychologie besucht hast. Ähm das haben die halt jetzt mit mit ein paar Jahren Forschung kombiniert, mit ein paar Millionen oder äh äh oder sonst was Kapital im Hintergrund.
Und haben das mal verfeinert mit einem größeren Team eine längere Zeit. Und natürlich und und vor allem mit einem spezifischen, mit der spezifischen Idee strategisch zu kommunizieren.
Was heißt denn strategisch kommunizieren? In dem Bereich heißt das, du sagst jeder Person.
Dies da draußen gibt, genau das, was du dieser Person sagen musst, damit du auf das Verhaltens, auf das, auf das Wahlergebnis,
hinwirkst, was du gerne hättest. Das heißt, einem nicht entschlossenen,
äh oder einem einem stark an Hillary Clinton zweifelnden Demokraten gibst du möglichst Informationen, die Hillary Clinton für ihn unwählbar machen.
In Abhängigkeit seiner Eigenschaften.
Um in Abhängigkeit von dem, was du sonst noch über ihn weißt.
Bist so ängstlich, na ja, dann.
Machen wir die halt noch mehr Angst.
Du bist leicht entflammbar, dann Portion Hass.
Genau, das heißt wir wir kommunizieren
Strategisch an bestimmte Bevölkerungsgruppen. Und da ist dann wieder dieses, also was ganz interessant ist in der Psychologie äh in der
Persönlichkeitspsychologie gibt's immer quasi Dimensionsmodelle und Typenmodelle, ne? Also ich hatte gerade schon gesagt, so Meier, Brix, Typen, Fragebogen, der dann irgendwie so und so viele Typen definiert. Ähm wie gesagt, eher im esoterischen Bereich ähm,
dann irgendwie so Dimensionsmodell, was ja eigentlich fließend ist. Aber am Ende hast du ganz klar definierst du dir Zielgruppen und die Zielgruppen sind im Prinzip Typen, ne? Stereotypen könnte man fast sagen. Äh für die du,
Zielgruppengerechte Ansprachen machst, ne? Wenn ich ein.
Politischen Nerd.
Wer mich davon überzeugen möchte Trump zu wählen muss was anderes sagen als wenn er was weiß ich irgendwelche Früher davon überzeugen will Trump zu wählen ja? Also da du machst einfach eine zielgerichtete,
an Zielgruppengerechte Ansprache.
Was haben sie dir eigentlich gesagt? Das ist ein Traumpaket hast.
Mich haben sie einfach nur bedroht.
Ähm.
So, ne? Das aber.
Das, was jetzt hier so quasi äh und da sind wir genau wieder bei dem Punkt, dass wir so so eine so etwas sehen, dieser Artikel fängt gut an. Der erklärt äh eine ganze Menge über Persönlichkeitspsychologie, macht aber einen Jähnbruch,
An der Stelle wo es nämlich um das Beeinflussen von Verhalten geht. Weil das, was die Leute ja am Ende hier hören, ist äh äh,
Michael oder
Michael, Miha, Miha, äh Kosinski hat Trump zur Wahl verholfen, ja? Bisher steht hier aber die ganze Zeit nur, dass der in der Lage war, Verhalten vorherzusagen. Da steht nirgendwo, dass der Verhalten manipuliert hat.
Nee, in Freibad, er ist ja auch selber gar nicht getan, sondern ein anderes Unternehmen, was ja angeblich nur seine Methoden.
Deswegen ja auch der Titel, er hat ja nur gezeigt, dass es die Wasserstoffbombe gibt und jemand anders hat sie dann gebaut, ne? Also das, wie gesagt, ist ein bisschen reißerisch. Da sind wir wieder in diesem Bereich. Das man eigentlich sagt, dieser Artikel ist macht ein paar unzulässige Schlüsse, der.
Dramatisiert etwas? Aber das, was da wirklich beschrieben wird
Ist tatsächlich einfach richtig und das ist auch das, wovor wir seit äh wovor wir seit Jahren äh warnen, ja, denn warum ich auch äh so viele Jahre später immer noch kein äh Facebook äh Profil habe. Ähm,
weil mit dieser mit diesem Wissen eben eine Unmenge an Macht,
einhergeht und diese Macht wird genutzt. Und wir konnten jahrelang froh sein, dass Facebook diese Macht nur für Marketing zu nutzen schien.
Und weil Facebook das offenbar nur für Marketing genutzt hat, haben sich dann eben andere hier eben SCL sich überlegt, na dann machen wir das halt für Wahlen und politische Beeinflussung. Aber entscheidend ist, hier gibt's einen logischen Bruch zwischen ähm,
Die die wissen viel über Menschen.
Und der Vorwurf der Wahlbeeinflussung. Weil Wahlbeeinfassung klingt halt so, als hätten sie konkret einen Menschen manipuliert, ne? Die haben aber eigentlich nur zielgruppenorientierte Werbung gemacht, wie jeder andere auch.
Ich sage nicht, dass das jetzt äh besonders cool ist und ich will das Problem auch nicht runterspielen. Ähm aber wenn du das jetzt kombinierst mit, ne, also wenn du.
Aber es ist nichts Neues in dem.
Es ist nichts Neues. Ähm aber es ist natürlich gut, sich darüber äh darüber aufgeklärt zu sein und sich über diesem, über diese,
im Dunkeln wirkenden Mächte. Im Klaren zu sein und zu wissen, wie diese Mechanismen
funktionieren, aber was mitgenommen wurde ist eben ja, die haben über irgendeiner hat über Facebook ganz viele Daten gesammelt, auf einmal war Trump Präsident, ja? Äh und natürlich wirkt dieser
ähm.
Dieser dieser Typ der also irgendwie einer dieser Chefs der Alexander nichts ähm von der Firma Cambridge America, die eben auch mit diesem SC.
Analytica.
Äh äh Cabrio Analytica äh zusammengehört, der sagte, es ist ein Privileg vor ihnen, verehrte Zuhörer über die Macht von Big Data und der Psychographie im Wahlkampf zu sprechen. Klar, die haben sich damit auseinandergesetzt, ganz klarer Fall, ja. Ähm.
Übrigens sehr spannend ist ähm wir haben letzte Woche uns sehr ausführlich mit Steve Bennon von Breitbart unterhalten. Äh äh auseinandergesetzt, ja? Ähm,
und der Steve Bennon von äh Bright Barth ist im Vorstand von Cambridge Analytica.
Surprise, ja? So, ähm der hat äh und ist ja, wie wir uns erinnern. Der äh Chefstrategieberater von Donald Trump, ja? Und der hat eben mit diesen Leuten äh zusammengearbeitet. Ähm.
Anfragen gibt es auch äh aus der äh Schweiz und in Deutschland und die machen sich natürlich da jetzt drüber Gedanken. Äh psychologisches Targeting zu nutzen, um,
in der Wahlwerbung dieses zum Einsatz zu bringen. Das ist beunruhigend, das ist alles das ist alles andere als schön.
Aber jetzt seht, jetzt sieht man mal, wovor wir äh die ganze Zeit gewarnt haben. Äh wenn wir über politische Einflussnahme reden. Nur äh.
Was wir hier sehen ist nicht.
Also es ist im Prinzip am Ende nichts anderes als zielgruppenorientierte Werbung, wie sie die ganzen,
Unternehmen seit Jahren,
mit Hilfe des Internets, Social Media und Trackern und dieser ganzen äh legalen und illegalen Datensammlungen äh nutzen, ja? Und mit dem mit dem gleichen,
mit dem gleichen.
Mit der gleichen Herleitung kannst du den eben auch sagen, so meine Fresse äh ich habe hier eine Puderdose, ich nehme das Beispiel, ich habe hier eine Puderdose von Mac in der Hand. Make-up-Marke, dass ich die gekauft habe, das haben die doch von langen, von langer Hand geplant,
Die haben mich doch manipuliert, dass ich die Scheiße kaufe. Ja, haben sie. Es nennt sich Werbung.
Jetzt ist natürlich so, dass es jetzt hier diese,
Rolle von Cambridge Analytica, die arbeiten halt mit den Daten, die sie jetzt aus äh Facebook und anderen öffnen, also sozusagen den öffentlich scratebaren Informationen,
Likes, die sich abfragen lassen, Profile, die sich auslesen lassen. Alles, was in irgendeiner Form
Facebook ohnehin an jeden herausgibt oder zumindest an bestimmte Kreise. Sie können ja dann nochmal äh jeden, der sie liked, äh wahrscheinlich auch nochmal ein Stück weit äh weiter auslesen, je nachdem, wie so die eigentlichen Einstellungen sind,
Wenn man jetzt die Möglichkeiten von Facebook selber zum Beispiel auch nochmal daneben hält, hat man ja auch schon diese Diskussionen über die neuen Algorithmen, die allein schon zur Auswahl, was zeige ich dir überhaupt all in deiner Timeline macht
da ist natürlich eine ganz andere Datenbasis, wenn an dieser Stelle, was wir nicht wissen, ähnliche,
Methoden zum Einsatz kämen wäre natürlich die Datenbasis dafür wiederum noch viel, viel, viel, viel umfahrreicher.
Facebook hat im Prinzip diesen Effekt genutzt, sie haben gesagt, okay, alles was wir haben wollen, ist Conversion Rate, die Leute auf der Seite halten, die Leute zufriedenhalten, ja? Ähm,
Wir wollen denen, dass Facebook liefern, was sie glücklich macht, damit sie länger hier bleiben.
Damit wir in mehr Werbung mit einspielen können, damit sie die Werbung klicken, damit unsere Kunden glücklich sind, ja? Und Facebook hat damit im Prinzip so ein, so ein Selbstverstärkenden Durchlauferhitzer gebaut, der jetzt immer wieder äh als als Filterbubble äh ähm.
Präzisiert und benannt wird. Das nämlich durch dein eigenes Verhalten und durch deine Interessen ähm Facebook beibringst,
Dich in deiner Meinung zu bestärken? Kurz gesagt, ne? Filter Babels könnte man auch wieder fünf Seminare drüber halten, aber letztendlich heißt das, dass Facebook in das du blickst, ist dein Facebook. Ne, es ist nicht das, was du siehst, es ist.
Es ist wie du es siehst und wie du siehst definiert, was dir gezeigt wird. Ähm.
Kleinen Spieglein an der Wand.
Ja so und so kommt
so kommen diese Effekte zustande. So, was haben die jetzt am Ende gemacht? So, die Maßnahmen der Firma sind radikal, steht hier, ne? Ab Juli zwanzig sechzehn wird für Trump Wahlhelfer eine App bereitgestellt
Mit der sie erkennen können, welche politische Einstellung und welchen Persönlichkeitstyp die Bewohner eines Hauses haben.
Wenn Trumps Leute an der Tür klingeln, dann nur bei jenen, die die App als empfänglich für seine Botschaften einstuft. Die Wahlhelfer haben,
Auf den Persönlichkeitstyp des Bewohners angepasste Gesprächsleitfäden bereit. Ne? Also der Trump,
Wahlhelfer steht bei mir vor der Tür und erzählt mir was anderes als jemand anderem, weil die App weiß, für welche Argumente ich empfänglich bin und für welche nicht,
Ähm ich weiß, also es ist.
Ich ich will diese Sache so ein bisschen,
In dem was wie sie wirklich funktioniert ein bisschen entzaubern und erklären. Das heißt nicht, dass ich damit den Effekt, der dadurch erzielt werden kann, herunterspielen möchte
Der das ist genau das Problem, was passiert, was entsteht, wenn du an einer zentralen Stelle zu viel Wissen,
Weil dieses dieses mit diesem Wissen können sich eben solche Dinge,
anstellen lassen und es ist ähm eigentlich nur naheliegend,
dass ein Unternehmen hingeht und sagt, alles klar, da da gibt's doch eine Nachfrage. So, dann wollen wir diese Nachfrage mal.
Und dann, dass sie dann auf einmal mit solchen Leuten wie Steve Bennon und Donald Trump auf einmal da sitzen, während offenbar der größere Teil der Gesellschaft, der aufgeklärten liberalen Gesellschaft, sagt so,
man darf doch nicht die Wahl beeinflussen, ne? Wahlbeeinflussung machen wir nur durch diese durch diese hässlichen Plakate, die wir äh einen Monat lang äh an die Wand.
Nun Fernsehspots.
Und durch Fernsehsports, ja?
Und Talkshows.
Ruht durch Talkshows. Aber aber wie jetzt äh die Daten, die die Leute uns nutzen, auch,
die die Leute uns geben auch zu nutzen, das geht aber so nicht. Ähm ich will nicht sagen, dass ich dieses, dass ich das gut finde, ne. Aber es ist äh es ist, es ist eben wichtig, dass äh.
Was getan werden kann, wird halt auch irgendwann getan und das kann halt jetzt getan werden und deswegen wird.
Ja und das ist das, wovor immer äh äh,
gewählt, äh, gewarnt wurde. Ja, die Firma unterteilt die US-Bevölkerung in zweiunddreißig Persönlich,
Persönlichkeitstypen und hat sich nur auf siebzehn Schaden äh konzentriert. Klar. Weil die anderen eh irrelevant waren. Die haben einfach äh effizient gearbeitet, die haben halt überlegt, wo,
Und das ist eigentlich alles, ja? Also streng genommen ist, wenn man das jetzt mal die haben, diese Daten genutzt, um ihre Bemühungen effizient einzusetzen,
Es gibt so und so viele Bundesstaaten, in denen das Ergebnis ohnehin feststeht, egal was wir den Leuten erzählen
Alles klar. Um die kümmern wir uns nicht. Es gibt Swing States, in denen wir die Wahl gewinnen oder verlieren können, auf die konzentrieren wir uns. Ah, es gibt Leute, die wollen dieses hören, äh damit sie uns wählen oder Hillary Clinton nicht wählen. Alles klar, dann erzählen wir ihnen das.
Ja, jetzt kann man sich natürlich auch vorstellen, warum zum Beispiel äh jetzt gleich immer die nächste Verschwörungstheorie loszutreten. Äh meine Facebook ist.
Noch in einem gewissen,
noch in einem gewissen Ordnungsrahmen einer äh verhältnismäßig freiheitlichen äh Gesellschaft in den USA. Es gibt ja aber nicht nur Facebook, es gibt ja auch,
andere Systeme in anderen Ländern, VK zum Beispiel ist so ein bisschen das russische Facebook, wo ja auch so die Gründer vor ein, zwei Jahren,
mal so ins Ausland gegangen sind, weil sie na ja, eigentlich ja nicht so sich so richtig äh trennen wollten von ihrem Baby, aber dann doch dazu gedrängt wurden, das doch mal zu tun
In China gibt's natürlich auch ein ähnliches System. Ich habe aber jetzt gerade keine Ahnung, wie äh weißt du nochmal, was du so aus Facebook, Äquivalent.
Ist das nicht Weekchat, aber das ist nicht, ich weiß nicht, ob.
Jetzt geht es halt auf diese Messenger, da gibt's nur dieses Vibo, ich blicke mal bei den chinesischen Sachen nicht durch, aber ganz offensichtlich, Facebook ist zwar
verhältnismäßig erfolgreich weltweit, aber ist ja nicht das einzige System dieser Art. Äh hier gibt es halt noch diese privatrechtliche äh Kapsel. In anderen Ländern sind natürlich die Zugriffe auf diese Datenbestände eine ganz
ganz andere und wenn man sich halt jetzt auch dieses Wissen, diese Möglichkeit, Psychologie herauszulesen, aus.
Wenn diese Firma von Cambridge Analytica meint, vor den in den USA hätten sie entsprechende Profile von zweihundertzwanzig Millionen Leuten,
dreihundert leben da. Wenn du mal die Kinder rausnimmst, sind das sozusagen alle. Und wenn du irgendwie alle hast und du,
hast, sagen wir mal, ein anderes Interesse als nur eine Wahl zu beeinflussen, sondern vielleicht einfach generell irgendein Machtsystem zu erhalten
dann sind das natürlich sehr dankbare Informationsquellen, die dann ein weiteres Handeln und wie du sozusagen mit bestimmten Bevölkerungsgruppen umgehst, natürlich äh nachhaltig beeinflussen können. So, aha, wer ist denn hier überhaupt aufmüpfig in seinem ganzen persönlich,
Wo sind denn diese ganzen Leute, die
die ganze Zeit nach nach neuen Ideen suchen und die irgendwie bestehendes in Frage stellen und das sind natürlich dann die ersten, auf die man losmarschiert,
Und das ist schon ein,
Das ist schon so eine Perspektive, äh wo man sich halt äh gut überlegen muss, ob man da noch ja, selber erstmal mitspielen will und was man dann auch im Zweifelsfall da noch unternehmen sollte.
Ich würde gerne, also wir haben auch einen Artikel verlinkt äh von Jens Scholz, äh der ähm,
so der erste Blogpost zu sein, schien der da eben konkret sich dieses Ding halt ein bisschen gerader gerückt hat. Und ich würde mich äh würde gerne zwei Dinge daraus nochmal
zitieren und mich ihnen anschließen, weil wir jetzt so lange darüber geredet haben, ja? Ähm also.
Einmal sagt er Barn.
Also nicht nur die Trump-Kampagne sei ja beeinflusst worden, sondern auch Brexit auch, nicht, ja, das waren ja noch so die Aus.
Also der eine Satz, den ich sehr schön finde, wie kommen Menschen immer wieder auf die irgendwie religiös Mathematik hörige Idee, dass man menschliches Verhalten derart leicht kategorisieren, vorhersagen und dann sogar steuern könnte,
Ähm der Satz danach ist ein nicht ganz,
zulässiger Schluss, deswegen nehme ich den nicht und am Ende schreibt er, das ist, denke ich, das will ich jetzt auch diesem langen, was diesen langen Ausführungen nochmal.
Anhängen. Nur zur Klärung, falls das anders rüberkommt. Ich schreibe hier nicht darüber, dass Targeting in Werbung nicht funktioniere,
Äh das tut es durchaus und ist ein wichtiges Werkzeug sowohl für Trumps als auch für die Brexit-Kampagne gewesen,
denn die wollten ja ihre Zielgruppen erreichen und haben das auch geschafft.
Man hätte diese Kommunikationsstrategie gar nicht so erfolgreich fahren können, gäbe es die Möglichkeiten nicht, Zielgruppen für Social Ads gezielt anzusteuern,
Es ist,
Aber nicht schwer, die zu finden, dafür brauche ich keine Scoring Modelle, die am Ende auch noch zur Ursache des Erfolgs hochgeschrieben werden. Also, er sagt, das Ding ist es, das gibt es, das ist ein Problem,
Großes, aber auch nicht erst seit gestern. Aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so, als hätte jetzt ausgerechnet diese
Cambridge Analytica, die gesamten USA manipuliert so in der Massenhypnose, weil das sind die geheimen Psychologen und haben es geschafft, äh, darauf hinzuwirken. Die haben einfach äh
In Zusammenarbeit mit Breitbart, ja, es geschafft zu jedem.
Das zu sagen, was er brauchte.
Um das Wahlergebnis zu erzielen, was sie im Rahmen einer einer eines Erkennen der eines Erkennens der Lage, als ihr strategisches Ziel hatten,
und das ist ihnen gelungen. Und dass es ihnen mit Hilfe unter anderem dieser Methoden gelungen.
Wie es ihnen auch gelungen ist, äh mit Breitbarten einen Haufen äh Lunetix irgendwie zu mobilisieren. Aber nicht eine einzige, nicht eine Einzelne dieser Gruppen äh oder eine einzelne dieser Methoden war am Ende wahlentscheidend
Es ist aber entscheidend zu erkennen, welche welche verschiedenen Methoden da zum Einsatz gekommen sind,
Und auch wie vielfältige Weise äh Menschen versuchen, Verhalten zu.
Zu optimieren und zu manipulieren. Und wenn deine Typen, die du durch eine Straße schickst,
Am Ende nur bei denen Klingeln, wo sie, wo sie überhaupt eine Erfolgswahrscheinlichkeit haben und ihre ihre Ressourcen nicht darauf verballern, mit Leuten zu diskutieren, bei denen sie eh nichts gewinnen können, dann ist das eine Effizienzsteigerung und dann kannst du bei mehr Leuten klingeln und dann ist das gut.
Für die.
Ja, also
Man darf sich auf jeden Fall jetzt hier auch nicht so blind jetzt dieser äh Feierei, diese dieses Unternehmens dort äh anschließen, ja? Das ist ja im Prinzip für die ja jetzt auch nochmal wirklich ein interessanter Marketingstand äh hier so äh
genannt zu werden. Ähm gibt da auch äh Mixtreviews und durchaus äh auch äh andere Meinungen darüber, wie effizient die jetzt so sind. Er hat ja auch selber in dem Vortrag, der wurde auch in dem anderen Artikel angesprochen, deswegen verlinken wir den auch nochmal. Stellt er ja so vor, was ja sozusagen ihre Kernleistung gewesen war und das war ja gar nicht Trump
Es ging ja erstmal um diesen Ted Gruß, den sie ja angeblich sozusagen zu so einem tollen Kandidaten aufgebaut haben, aus dem Nichts, der dann aber am Ende auch gegen Trump äh verloren hat.
Also von daher ist das alles äh Mixbag. Also wir haben jetzt hier sozusagen
nicht unbedingt die die Smoking Gun äh gefunden, die die jetzt diese ganze Wahl entscheiden äh entschieden hat. Aber der Artikel,
Weist auf ein interessantes Phänomen hin, dass wir uns sehr wohl in großer Geschwindigkeit solchen äh
Techniken nähern und deren Effizienz beim nächsten Mal schon wieder ganz anders aussehen kann.
Ja, aber also ne, was es sehr eindrucksvoll ähm demonstriert ist.
Was solche, was wir alles für Verhaltenstraces in sozialen Netzwerken lassen und was sich aus denen alles,
erkennen und vorher sagen lässt und das Entscheidende dabei ist warum das so krass ist, weil weil
die ja sofort im Maschinenlesbaren Format da liegen. Also was als äh als ich Psychologie studiert habe, ne? Was war das für eine was war das anstrengend
An so ein paar Datenpunkte zu kommen, die du am Ende analysieren konntest, ne? Wenn du jetzt irgendwie deine deine.
Wenn deine Leute, die da irgendwie dran teilgenommen haben an deiner Studie. Ähm, sechzig,
Sechzig Fragen beantwortet haben, ne? Da musstest du den zwischendurch schon nur mal einen Tee und einen Schokoriegel bringen, damit die den Fragebogen zu Ende gemacht haben. Heute
müssen die einmal dein Facebook-Freund werden und liefern dir so viele Datenpunkte frei Haus dass du traumhafte Analysen machen kannst, ja? Als ich ähm mich letztens mal mit so einem äh mit so einem,
Analysten bei Facebook unterhalten habe und gesagt habe, Mensch, dass ich ähm in meiner äh,
Diplomarbeit irgendwie sowas wie um die zweitausend Variablen hatte
ja? Äh mit denen ich, mit denen ich äh jonglieren konnte, ne. Da hat er anerkennend die Braue hochgezogen und sagte halt so, ja, also für was weiß ich, wann ich die gemacht habe, war das ja nicht schlecht,
Na, aber was die haben, ne? Also es werden die sitzen da, dieses Facebook gibt es und da gibt es Unmengen an Menschen, Data Scientist, Statistiker und sonst was, die einfach mal.
Uneingeschränkten Zugang auf diese Datenbank haben,
Die können damit die Fragen beantworten, die sie wollen und das ist bei jedem Unternehmen, bei jedem dieser Daten äh Unternehmen nicht anders. Ich erinnere mich da irgendwann. Ich glaube, das habe ich auch schon mal äh erwähnt. Wenn Amazon für ihre Werbung, ja, für ihre Werbeschaltung da,
AB Versuch macht, ja? Geht die Anzeige besser oder die? Äh das dauert für die ein paar Sekunden,
Es macht das Ding automatisch, ja? Das heißt, sie entwickeln zwei Werbeanzeigen oder zwei Empfehlungen, das das ist schon einprogrammiert, dass das System einen AB Versuch macht und und automatisch auf auf das Zielkriterium klickt und kauft, hinarbeitet,
So, da können wir noch so so lange sagen. Die empfehlen mir was, was ich schon längst habe. Amazon ist doof,
mag sein, dass wir immer mal wieder über ein Artifakt dieses Algorithmusses stolpern.
Aber am Ende musst du dir keine Sorgen machen, dass diese, dass diese Modelle, die die da zur Anwendung bringen, irgendwie äh ineffizient wären oder nicht äh sich die ganze Zeit optimieren würden.
Ja und auch sowas muss man auch nicht unbedingt ein Zeichen sein, dass irgendwas nicht funktioniert. Das kann auch einfach eine reine Verifikation oder wir probieren's einfach nochmal und was weiß ich.
Ja. Das ist genau, das ist wieder die Tante, äh die dann im im Psychologiestudium herbeigeführt wird, um die komplette Forschung.
Meine Oma, da ist das alles ganz an.
Die komplette Forschung der letzten hundert Jahre völliger Unsinn, weil meine Oma hat gestern äh nicht die Rosinen aus den Stuten gepickt. Wer also das sehen würde ähm.
Am Ende macht es die Masse und ähm bei bei der Masse sind dann eben auch äh wenige Werte hinterm oder wen weitere Stellen hinterm Komma immer noch äh sehr entscheidend. Willkommen
in der neuen Zeit, in der wir alle freiwillig unsere Daten in solche Datenbanken füttern, damit am Ende äh irgendwelche Shady-Unternehmen,
die analysieren und damit irgendwelchen Schädigen zum Gewinn der Wahl verhelfen.
Ja, nach dieser Kurzmeldung. Also jetzt haben wir allein schon auf die letzten beiden Themen schon äh fast zwei Stunden verwendet.
Ich will trotzdem noch eine Sache gerne sagen
Weil wenn du dir äh warum dieser Begriff der Wahlbeeinflussung und so da immer wieder so eine Rolle spielt, ist ja, warum ist das so krass, weil wir dieses Modell der Demokratie äh dass er eigentlich vor so sagt, dass,
dass die Leute da wählen und die haben sich darüber Gedanken gemacht und dann gibt es dieses Korrektiv der Öffentlichkeit. Wir haben so alles, diese, wir haben alle diese Modelle, ne, wie wir uns eigentlich das mit der Demokratie vorgestellt haben, auch die Kräfteverteilung, ne?
Und dann haben wir hier diese fünfte Kraft oder vierte oder welche auch immer das dann ist, denn die Medien und die sind die, die sind das Gegengewicht und und jetzt hast du auf einmal eine
Lügenpresse Lügenpresse, Fake News, Social Bots und diese ganze Scheiß und natürlich ist das alles eine sehr,
unberuhigende Entwicklung und ich möchte jetzt nicht am Ende, dass die Leute mitnehmen, dass wir das ähm, dass wir das irgendwie kleinreden.
Sie auf gar keinen Fall. Grade wenn man sieht, was Fake News alles so äh ausrichten kann.
Ja, Fake News.
Zum Beispiel in den USA. Äh da gibt's ja also jetzt haben wir auch schon viel über die Trump-Kampagne äh gesprochen und was dort alles so blanciert wurde und mal ganz unabhängig, wie das alles so getarget war
was da halt alles irgendwie alles so aus dem äh Zauberhut gezogen wurde. Ist ja wirklich unfassbar. Ich hab's auch nicht alles jetzt im Detail verfolgt, eine Geschichte, die mich jetzt auch erst vor kurzem äh,
ja an mich heran äh getragen wurde auch aus so einer verhältnismäßig hm.
Na ja zum.
Huch auf der Ostgala sehr aufgeschlossen für neue Informationen,
war diese Pizza äh Gate Story, die es wohl dort auch gab, äh von der ich bis dahin nur so am Rande irgendwas gehört hatte, eine eine Absabstruse, ich weiß nicht, kennst du, hast du das eigentlich besser verstanden? Also es gibt da irgendwie so eine Pizzaladen Comic
Pizza, komm mit, irgendwas, Pizza geht. Ähm.
Also offenbar haben sie in den, wenn ich.
Pinkpong, genau, komm mit Pinkpong, ja, so ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein Pizzaladen, der angeblich irgendwie so die die zentrale äh der demokratischen National Comity
ist irgendwie, wo sie ein, ein Kinderpornoring irgendwie halten und Horrorstories gingen da irgendwie rum.
Und ähm tja,
Tatsächlich gibt's halt diesen Laden auch wirklich. Und diese Storys gingen halt irgendwie rum und es waren halt äh.
Ja ja aber warum warum gingen die rum, ne? Also wenn ich das, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, haben die in diesen Podesta-E-Mails gesucht, die es ja bei Viki Leaks gibt und haben festgestellt, dass die sich regelmäßig zum Pizzaessen verabreden in diesem Laden. Und,
irgendjemand meinte dann wohl oder es ist glaube ich wohl auch eine Tatsache oder auch nicht. Ich kenne mich in diesen Kreisen nicht aus. Es gibt wohl das Gerücht, dass ähm,
Pädophile.
In der Coachsprache. Na, wir können ja nicht, können ja nicht das, worüber sie reden, ne? Beim Namen nennen und dass es da diesen Begriff äh Pizza, dass der eine Rolle spielen würde. Das kann ich nicht beurteilen.
Ich hätte gerne eine kleine Pizza und so mit äh.
Lass uns doch so. Und dann sind halt irgendwelche Verschwörungstheoretiker äh auf den Gedanken gekommen, okay? Äh die verabreden sich da andauernd zu Pizza. Es ist doch ein Kinderschänderring,
So und dann ist der in diese Pizzeria reingesitzt da jemand in diese Pizzeria reingegangen und haben sie festgestellt, da hängen irgendwie auch noch Bilder von Kindern an der Wand oder so und dann war die Theorie halt perfekt,
So hat so ging das halt rum.
So gegen das Rom und es glauben irgendwie viele Leute,
Und ähm jetzt mal möchte man ja meinen äh nach der Wahl sollte irgendwie das alles mal wieder ein Ende haben, aber offensichtlich geht's jetzt erst so richtig los
Denn äh am Sonntag stürmte also ein achtundzwanzigjähriger Mann mit einer äh Waffe in diese,
Comics, Ping Pong, Pizza rein, also ich weiß gar nicht, ob's da mehrere von gibt oder wirklich nur einen einzigen und ich nehme mal alles jetzt ein einziger,
bedrohte irgendwie einen Angestellten und äh,
Einen weiteren Kollegen, Gäste und so weiter und ähm somit vorgehaltener äh Waffe. Die konnten dann irgendwie schnell abhauen
oder haben sich irgendwie äh aus der Affäre gezogen, wie wohl auch die meisten anderen Leute, die dann in dem Moment einfach waren und der hatte aber dann,
irgendwie auch nochmal abgedrückt, mindestens einmal.
Aber keinen getroffen.
Hat jetzt keinen getroffen, also es war jetzt kein Blutbad äh und äh die Polizei wurde auch schnell gerufen und die haben den irgendwie fünfundvierzig Minuten später haben sie ihn dann irgendwie auch äh verhaftet, aber er meinte dann halt in seiner Vernehmung
Ja, äh, er muss unbedingt jetzt mal diesen Pizzagate Anschuldigung äh selber untersuchen,
Weil macht ja offensichtlich sonst keiner
und deswegen hat er sich da halt irgendwie mit drei Waffen äh bewaffnet und ist da halt einfach rein, um irgendwie keine Ahnung, was verhältnismäßig planlos.
Um die Kinder zu befreien oder was auch immer jetzt irgendwie so,
Diese Blüten, solche Blüten treibt das, ne? Spannend äh ist halt noch diese dieses Trump-Lager hat das ja ähm.
Also die ich glaube sogar Leute aus seinem äh Kabinett haben diese Sache, ja, dieser, er hat zumindest ja so ein bisschen zu Aufschwung äh verhäufen, ja? Ähm.
Und äh zumindest das auch irgendwie äh zur Kenntnis genommen und irgendwie verbreitet, weil es dann nämlich irgendwann mal äh wie es eben in der Breitbartstrategie ähm,
läuft äh,
in den normalen Medien, in der Lügenpresse auch anerkannt wurde, dass es da etwas gibt, was so heißt und jetzt muss man irgendwie gucken und ähm da wurde dann eben auch von von Seiten der der Trump-Unterstützer,
In diese Richtung,
gestupst und das ist natürlich auch wieder äußerst beunruhigend. Wollen wir das Thema Fake News, was wir eigentlich ja für diese Sendung haben wollen, jetzt wusste ich nicht, dass wir so lange über Persönlichkeitspsychologie reden würden. Ähm,
denn nochmal in der nächsten Sendung aufgreifen.
Ja, können wir machen. Ich meine, hier gibt's jetzt in dem Sinne auch nicht viel zu berichten, außer, dass wir einfach auch merken, diese das Netz hat da hier auf jeden Fall ein Problem
So und ähm,
Facebook hat ja auch irgendwas angekündigt, wie sie dem jetzt äh entgegengehen wollen. Ich muss zugeben, mir das nicht äh durchgelesen zu haben. Es gab auf jeden Fall da eine entsprechende Verlautbarung von Facebook, dass sie dieses Problem jetzt quasi angehen. Und das ist natürlich auch ein so ein
so wieder so ein, so ein, so eine schwierige Sache, das hatten wir ja vorhin auch schon, nicht? Also mit diesen Algorithmen, so dieses wer entscheidet den jetzt eigentlich, was du sehen sollst? Ja, dann gibt's halt immer so diese Grundaussage mit, na ja, ich möchte ja hier gerne äh volle Daten äh und Recherchehoheit haben. Ich möchte nichts vorgefiltert
kommen. Ich filtere das halt sozusagen in meinem Hirn. Andererseits kriegt man mittlerweile auch schon wieder so viel Scheiße auf den Tisch, dass man schon ganz dankbar ist, wenn äh irgendein Mechanismus, einem das vielleicht schon mal so weit rausfiltert, dass es nicht mehr voll mit
Hass oder eben auch Fehlwahrnehmung ist. Und dann ist natürlich wieder die Frage, wer definiert was, was was war oder falsch ist
News sind ja nun zunächst einmal Berichterstattung und können ja tatsächlich auf irgendwelche Missstände auch wirklich hinweisen.
Was ist sozusagen das Kriterium dafür? Äh dass etwas nicht stimmt,
Wo steht die Wahrheit, an der du das äh überprüfen kannst, dass etwas nicht stimmt, vor allem wenn es sich um was Neues handelt?
Kann man überhaupt Fake News daran hindern, zu entstehen und vermutlich? Nein.
Es ist ja auch nicht so, als wäre das jetzt unbedingt was Neues, ne, dass jemand Unwahrheiten in die Welt setzt. Also, dass äh das gab's auch schon vorher, dass Menschen. Ne.
Damals. Und oft. Da muss man sich nur mal äh anschauen, das ist immer sehr unterhaltsam.
Neu ist, dass wir irgendwie, dass das anhand dieses Internet so ein bisschen aus den Fugen gerät, also es gibt eigentlich keine neuen Phänomene.
Ist nur billiger geworden, sie hervorzubringen.
Es ist billiger, sie hervorzubringen und wir haben irgendwie dieses es ist irgendwie so aus den die Welt ist so ein bisschen aus den Fugen geraten, was äh die die Möglichkeit des sich wieder.
Einfachens angeht, ja? Während du früher als Verschwörungstheoretiker vielleicht nochmal mit Leuten konfrontiert wurdest, die äh gesagt haben, hör mal, ähm.
Vielleicht,
sind die auch einfach zum Mond geflogen, weil es weniger aufwendig war als diese Verschwörungstheorie, die du da aufgebaut hast, ja, das war wahrscheinlich einfach ökonomischer, da wirklich hinzufliegen. Ähm,
Sorgen, diese Selbstverstärkungsmechanismen der sozialen Netzwerke. Äh du suchst dir das, was dir gefällt, dass du soziale Netzwerke weißt, irgendwann, was dir gefällt, liefert dir das, was dir gefällt? Ähm,
zu diesen Filterbubbles, in denen Leute sich dann eben bewegen und äh wahrnehmen.
Und dann kommen diese Fallen, diese einzelnen Phänomene, in diesen Filterbubbles auf eben viel fruchtbareren Boden.
Ist es ja, ich muss auch sagen, ich bin da etwas ähm etwas ratlos
wie man dem Phänomen jetzt dann hinterhergehen soll, weil man auch wie es wirklich das Gefühl hat, derzeit poppen irgendwie äh drei neue äh Phänomene äh auf, die irgendwie unangenehm zu handeln sind, äh während man in der Zeit bestenfalls mal sich mit an einem äh abarbeiten kann und auch so dieses
Na ja, man muss ja irgendwie medienkompetenter äh werden. Ist ja auch nochmal so eine Aussage, die wir gerne treffen, die sicherlich auch nicht falsch ist,
aber die die dadurch, dass es so viele neue Phänomene sind, die dann von einem selbst von den Experten vielleicht zu dem Zeitpunkt noch gar nicht richtig verstanden sind, wie wie soll man da überhaupt noch mithalten,
ist nicht äh ist nicht schön hier, dieses Internet, was wir immer so geil fanden. Das ist irgendwie äh anstrengen.
Ja
Da gibt's ja dann auch die Leute, die liegen dann auch noch ganz viel. Das ist ja auch noch so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein Phänomen hier äh unser äh Spezialfreund Rudio äh A Sanchez. Hat wohl doch noch Internet,
In seinem äh seiner Behausung,
so hat Wicki Leaks jetzt mal wieder was äh rausgehauen und die diesmal traf es den NSA Untersuchungsausschuss, den wir ja hin und schon oft und häufig und vielfach äh konfliktiert haben,
Und was äh geleakt wurde waren Dokumente,
die wohl äh die niedrigste Geheimhaltungsstufe besaßen und im Rahmen dieses Ausschusses Abgeordneten beziehungsweise Ausschussmitgliedern vorgelegt wurden zur Einsicht,
Und zwar insofern, als dass sie eben auch konkret Zugriff auf Dateien bekamen, also,
wo sozusagen ein Dateizugriff auch möglich waren im Gegensatz zu den höher klassifizierten Dokumenten die halt dann nur ausgedruckt in einem Raum äh vorgelegt wur.
VSNFD, Verschlusssache nur für den Dienstgebrauch. Die haben die äh digital bekommen, alles was da drüber ist, also äh was gibt's denn da noch? VSNFD, Verschlusssache.
Ja, dann streng daheim, tralala gibt's so wie vier, fünf verschiedene äh Klassifikations.
Burn After Reading und ähm,
die haben die nicht in digitaler Form erhalten, sondern mussten dann dahin. Und jetzt ist quasi das, was ihn digital als VSNFD,
Äh zugänglich war äh bei Vicky Leas gelandet. Neunzig Gigabyte. Äh neunzig Gigabyte, aber glaube ich deshalb, weil das größtenteils so,
grafische Scans von Faxen sind oder was auch immer die da haben die dann eben aufgrund der Bilddaten da drin nochmal so 'ne so 'ne so 'ne Größe entfalten. Aber das ist auch ein relativ umfangreiches Archiv.
Also es ist äh Level vier, Geheimhaltung, dadrüber gibt's dann noch Verschlusssache, vertraulich, geheim und streng geheim.
Na ja, so und jetzt mag man sich ja denken auf den ersten Blick so oh ja jetzt hier die geilen Dokumente und jetzt haben wir endlich mal Einblick in diese ganze Geschichte, nur na ja gut, das waren halt alles Dokumente, die den Mitgliedern des Ausschusses bereits vorlagen. Die waren jetzt in dem Sinne nicht
unbekannt, aber jetzt sind sie halt auch in der Öffentlichkeit und auch in der Opposition, also eigentlich durchgehend der komplette Ausschuss,
fand die Nummer überhaupt nicht geil. Das ging los beim Vorsitzenden Patrick Sensburg von der CDU,
brauch von einem Bärendienst, der äh hier äh erwiesen wurde, da ist man dann vielleicht auch erstmal nicht so richtig überrascht, aber auch die ähm,
Martina Rinner und der äh also Obfrau der Linken und Konstantin und Nord haben sie eigentlich im Prinzip ähnlich,
Geäußert, dass das äh kontraproduktiv werden an der Stelle vielleicht noch außer einer anderen Perspektive, nämlich dass sie es vor allem auch als Problem sehen, dass durch solche Maßnahmen,
äh Dokumente tendenziell dann eher noch klassifizierter werden und der Zugriff darauf im Rahmen einer solchen Ausschussarbeit noch schwieriger werden könnte. In der Zukunft und das ist so.
Noch viel. Also sie sagt sogar noch spezifischer, Martina Renner äh immer wieder haben die Geheimdienste behauptet,
Der NSA-Untersuchungs oder der Ausschuss sei ein Sicherheitsrisiko, weil die Dokumente von Abgeordneten der Position geliegt werden könnten,
ja? Also das ist quasi das sagen die schon, ne? So, das geben wir doch nicht dem NSA
den dem NS Aua äh hier die Abgeordneten der Opposition natürlich als allererstes, damit sind natürlich dann Martina Renner und Konstantin von Nortz ähm Hans-Christian Ströbele und solche,
Knallchargen gemeint, ne? Den kannst du doch nichts anvertrauen. Die sind doch hier total kontra, die sind voll anti. Die liegen das am Ende,
Die liegen, dass doch nur denen vertraue ich doch nicht, die sind doch gegen uns. Der, der so,
argumentierten die geheimdienste und mal Martina Renner sagt, na ja, wenn die ganz, wenn jetzt neunzig Gigabyte liegst liegen,
Das liegt gibt genau solchen Angriffen auf unsere Einsichtnahme, auf unsere Aufklärungsarbeit. Äh weiteren Vorschub.
Und äh das ist natürlich interessant, dass die derartig äh,
scharf darauf reagieren. Hätte ich auch ehrlich gesagt nicht mit gerechnet. Ich habe eigentlich gedacht, dass die sich vor die Bühne stellen und sagen, oh, ist doch nicht schlecht, wenn da jetzt mal jeder reingucken kann. Jetzt seht ihr ja nicht mal, was was da abgeht. Ähm,
aber allgemein zeigten sich also alle Mitglieder des NSL-Untersuchungsausschusses, die sich dazu geäußert haben durch die Bank äh.
Na ja und das hat jetzt auch ich meine, man hat mir natürlich dann auch erstmal gefragt so okay, das waren jetzt also Dokumente, die digital ausgegeben wurden.
Wenn man sowas so macht und das zumindest schon mal so Verschlusssache ist äh,
Ich meine, ich weiß nicht, wie du das machen würdest, aber wenn wenn ich sozusagen die ausgebende Stelle wäre, in einer solchen Situation ähm hätte ich das sicherlich auf eine Art und Weise rausgegeben, wie ich danach schnell feststellen könnte, was das League war
Ähm.
Ja, das ist ja immer die Idee zusammen, gerade wenn du jetzt irgendwie neunzig Gigabyte verteilst, ist natürlich den heiligen Idee, du brauchst bei jedem irgendwie einen kleinen irgendwo in den neun.
Wasserzeichen ein.
Du ein
äh um äh zu gucken, wer es am Ende geliegt hat. Äh das war jetzt hier nicht direkt der Fall, aber ähm denn diese Sachen lagen auf den Laufwerken des Ausschusses im Deutschen Bundestag. Die hatten offenbar irgendwie so,
falsch, ja oder sowas, ja.
Ist ja wirklich echt unfassbar.
Ähm aber es äh es habe sich,
Also es hat sich unter dem Haufen der bei Wiki Leaks lag eine Datei gefunden die äh dort nicht zugehöre.
Und.
Laut Spiegel äh ursprünglich nur Mitgliedern der Ausschüsse für auswärtige und für EU-Angelegenheit zugänglich gewesen ist,
Und das äh schränkt natürlich den Kreis.
Der Quelle ein, weil es unter, weil es weil jetzt vermutet wird es eine Person, die einerseits äh,
auf diesen Ausschuss für Auswärtige und EU-Angelegenheiten Zugriff hat,
Und andererseits auf die NSA-Geschichten. Das ist also jetzt so eine Hypothese, die da verfolgt wird und ähm das wird da jetzt äh gesucht werden, denn der Norbert Lammert hat quasi den äh,
Die die quasi wie soll man das sagen? Sie hat erlaubt, dass da jetzt ermittelt wird. Hat er also gesagt, ja, hier soll jetzt ermittelt werden.
Weil er hat die ganzen Abgeordneten und so ja ohnehin erstmal Immun wären und so. Also er hat jetzt quasi diese ne, wir stehen dem nicht im Wege, wir wollen wissen, was da los ist, wenn hier äh.
Äh wenn ihr diese Sachen liegen und ähm entsprechend wird da jetzt ermittelt. Und äh ich bin mal,
gespannt was dabei rauskommt, weil mich was mich wundert ist das wirklich alle Abgeordneten Mitglieder des NSA sagen wir wollen das nicht
Ich ich sehe auch dann schon die Verschwörungstheorien hochsprießen, dass äh äh Holio Assange in seiner Agenda für die Russen äh jetzt äh Angela Merkel angreift und wo Deutschland destabilisieren will, also auch solche Theorien ähm.
Werden da schon entfaltet. Ich bin mal ähm.
Spannt, welche, was jetzt da herausgefunden wird, vielleicht war's ein großer äh Hackingangriff äh vielleicht äh stellt sich raus, dass es irgendein Mitarbeiter war, vielleicht stellt sich raus, dass es irgendein Mitglied des NSA war.
Oder vielleicht ist es auch nur eine große ähm Diskreditions,
Diskreditierungsmaßnahme, wo man sagt, ach komm, dann nehmen wir jetzt hier mal die NSA äh Daten, die ja sowieso geliegt werden von der Opposition
Und dann äh legen wir da nochmal eine Datei dazu und dann haben wir gerade mal so eine schöne Überschneidung mit Personen X, der wir jetzt keine Ahnung haben, ob's die überhaupt gi
aber könnte ja sein, dass das sozusagen dann genau auf eine Person zuläuft und es sich einfach um alle dann auch diese Datei dann drin, da können ja nur sie. Die diese spezielle Mischung hergestellt haben oder halt irgendjemand, der das genauso zusammengestellt hat und das weiß man halt bei Dateien eben nicht.
Ich bin mal äh bin mal gespannt, was da jetzt die Aufklärungsarbeit äh äh an die ans Licht bringen wird. Also es wird auf jeden Fall Ermittlungen geben.
Und gleichzeitig kann ich mich jetzt in der Bewertung äh dieser Sachen da fehlt mir tatsächlich der der Überblick dazu, aber ähm Kai Biermann hat da einen ähm.
Eine Einschätzung zugegeben, der so sagt so allgemein sind äh diese Daten eher ähm als wenig aufschlussreich.
Im Sinne der Anklage einzustufen, ja? Ähm!
Im Sinne der Anklage, was, also welch.
Ja, also da wird hier also er schreibt ähm.
Die die von Wiki Leaks veröffentlichen, der Akten stellen zwar den größten Teil des Materials für den Ausschuss dar, aber äh
zum Beispiel der Ex-Kieskore-Vertrag zwischen NSA und Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz, den Zeit online im August zwanzig fünfzehn veröffentlicht hat, ist zum Beispiel ebenso wenig unter den Dokumenten, wie die Informationen zu den noch immer mysteriösen
Operation Monkey Showler, über die sie immer nicht sprechen dürfen. Das heiß,
quasi großen Fragen, ja? Kooperation Ex-Kieskor, das war ein Riesending, ne? Äh dieses Monkey-Show, da beschäftigt jetzt gerade den NSO, wie man immer äh hören kann bei bei technischer Aufklärung, denen wir an dieser Stelle zum zur fünfzigsten Folge gratulieren. Ähm,
Wir haben zweihundert letztens gehabt.
Ja, mehr.
Ähm.
Also er gruß in die Runde von hier. Ähm da, dass er also sagte, das wären die brennenden Fragen, ne, die wir ähm.
Die diesen Ausschuss beschäftigen, die die Öffentlichkeit beschäftigen, die uns alle beschäftigen und da passiert jetzt nichts. Ja, das äh und das ist also die erste Einschätzung, die kalbier man da zu äh gibt zusammen mit Patrick Beuth und ähm.
Dieser Einschätzung, die können wir jetzt hier erstmal nur so weitergeben, wir werden sehen, ob da noch irgendwas äh an krassen äh Erkenntnissen rauskommt und wir werden sehen, was da die Ermittlungen bringen.
Wer da am Ende das Interesse hatte.
So werden wir jetzt aber kein Interesse mehr dran bohren, haben wir denn auch Interesse.
Ja, gibt ein neues äh BND League äh bei Netzpolitik Org, veröffentlicht von Andre Meister, werden wir uns denke ich mal in der nächsten Sendung vielleicht nochmal mehr mit auseinandersetzen. Da geht es um das Projekt Anis Key.
Die äh Aufklärung Aniski, hm.
Aufklärung. Aniski. Anni Enniski. Hito Continuo.
Aufklärung, nicht standardisierter Kommunikation im Internet. Ähm,
wo es also darum geht, wie der Haushaltsplan für den NS äh für den für den NSA, für den BND aussieht ähm.
Und er bekommt also nächstes Jahr achthundertundsieben Millionen Euro, das sind zwölf Prozent mehr als im Jahr zwanzigsechzehn und ähm,
dann gab es ja schon die Erkenntnis, dass
einundzwanzig Komma fünf Millionen dafür geplant sind verschlüsselte Kommunikation besser überwachen zu können.
Ähm aber Netzpolitik Ork hat jetzt Dokumente vorliegen, aus denen er vorgeht, dass der BND für das Knacken von Verschlüsse und Ganze einhundertfünfzig äh Millionen Euro ausgeben will
dieses Jahr fünf Komma vier Millionen nächstes Jahr äh knapp sechzehn Millionen. Und der BND beklagt es also, dass er äh nur zehn von siebzig relevanten Diensten ähm mitlesen kann
und das möchte er gerne äh ändern und äh möchte also auf möglichst viele,
Messenging Methoden, die sich seiner Einsicht im Moment noch entziehen den Zugriff erlangen.
Tja.
Ja
Also ne, während äh es ist immer wieder schön darauf hinzuweisen, was so währenddessen passiert, während äh man versucht, äh diesen ganzen Kram irgendwie aufzuklären ähm,
Während man versucht, den Geheimdienst irgendwie äh.
Informationen zu entziehen oder vorzuenthalten, um vielleicht noch so einen Rest einer Privatsphäre in Zeiten der,
Freiwilligen und Unfreiwilligen Massenüberwachung zu erhalten sieht es also hier äh.
Insgesamt in kurzer Zeit eine ganze Menge Geld, die ausgegeben werden soll, ja.
Muss alles wieder rückgängig zu machen.
Ja. Also da werden wir hoffentlich auch nochmal die Gelegenheit zu haben, die Sache zu vertiefen.
Oder fällt dir da noch was zu ein?
Nee, ja, fällt mir nicht so ein, weil ich habe das ehrlich gesagt äh noch überhaupt nicht verfolgt.
Ja, da hoffen wir, dass der André mal nächste Woche mich vertritt oder so, dann kann er das nochmal genau erklären.
Und dann gab es die Vorstellung einer Grundrechte Carta für das Internet.
Das macht sich immer gut sowas.
Unter Digitalcarter Punkt EU.
Angeschaut.
Also ich habe äh ein paar ähm Kommentare dazu überflogen, aber ehrlich gesagt nicht die Zeit aufgebracht, mir das schon äh anzuschauen.
Ich weiß nur, dass jetzt hier äh diverse Netzaktivisten und Netzbewohner zusammengefunden haben, um da äh schwarmmäßig Thesen zusammenzutragen, die aber da auch teilweise schon ganz schön unter Feuer steht.
Ja, genau, also das ist ja immer so, wenn wenn irgendwo Leute äh hingehen und was machen, dann wird da drauf gekloppt. Ähm insofern ist das äh ist.
Äh das war auch irgendwie vorhersehbar ähm so ein bisschen aus welcher Richtung. Die Kritik kommt natürlich von den Leuten, die sich eigentlich an einem solchen Tisch sehen würden, die aber dann eben an diesem Tisch nicht saßen. Ähm,
Johnny Heusler äh hat das äh hier äh so ein bisschen dargestellt aus seiner persönlichen Perspektive Donny Hoster, Blogger bei Spreeblick
vor etwa einem Jahr erreichte mich eine Einladung von Giovanni, die Lorenzo in seiner Funktion als Mitglied des Kuratoriums der Zeitstiftung. Äh ein ganztiger Dialog soll es stattfinden zu der Frage und so weiter und
daraus ist das entstanden vor eben irgendwie vierzehn Monaten, dass sich eine Gruppe an Leuten zusammengesetzt hat, um eine ein Vorschlag einer digitalen Menschenrechts-Chata
zu entwickeln und ähm unter Digitalkater Punkt EU haben sie den jetzt veröffentlicht. Da oben steht groß dran, Beta.
Und dann steht da eine Gruppe von Bürgerinnen und Bürgern, die die Gestaltung, den die Gestaltung der digitalen Welt am Herzen liegt, hat
in den vergangenen vierzehn Monaten einen Vorschlag für eine Digitalkarte erarbeitet, der hiermit äh dem europäischen Parlament in Brüssel und der Öffentlichkeit zur weiteren Diskussion übergeben wird. Diskutieren sie mit,
unterzeichnen sie mit. Da ist die Kata hier abgebildet und da kann man dann äh offenbar äh kommentieren. Wenn du also auf Diskussionen gehst, dann hast du an jedem
Absatz offenbar die Möglichkeit den zu kommentieren.
Dann wollen sie das irgendwann dem Liebeausschuss vorstellen, um dann irgendwie quasi auf EU-Ebene äh
darauf hinzuarbeiten, dass sich eventuell auf eine,
eine Europaweite Versammlung zusammenfindet, die irgendwann diese digitalen Menschenrechte Rechte definieren soll. Ähm.
Es gab aber natürlich relativ viele äh viel viel ähm Punkte, die dann da irgendwie so angemerkt sind und ich ich ähm.
Glaube, das ist natürlich auch der dem Umstand geschuldet, dass da natürlich relativ viele äh dran äh mit ähm mitformuliert haben, ja. Ähm.
Viele Köche, viele Interessen, ja, das ist also nicht so, als hätte das eine Person geschrieben und entsprechend gibt's natürlich auch relativ viel
und wahrscheinlich bei niemanden bei keinem der Mitwirkenden der Einigkeit darüber. Ich bin dann zum Beispiel hier bei den Satz gestolpert, digitale Hetze, Mobbing, sowie Aktivitäten, die geeignet sind, den Ruf oder die Unversehrtheit einer Person ernsthaft zu gefährden, sind
zu verhindern. Ja, gleichzeitig ein pluraler, öffentlicher Diskussionsraum ist sicherzustellen. Ähm,
davor natürlich auch eine Zensur findet nicht statt, ne? Das sind natürlich im Detail dann doch recht widersprüchliche
Absätze, die sich da in Artikel fünf finden und die eben auch dann, glaube ich, die Pluralität derjenigen, die diesen Entwurf oder diesen Vorschlag erarbeitet haben.
Äh ein bisschen wiederspiegeln. Also wird man da jetzt relativ viel drüber diskutieren und äh dann bin ich mal gespannt
was daraus wird. Interessant ist, welche verschiedenen
Problemfelder hier entwickelt wurden. Also ich will jetzt weniger also da es ein Beta ist äh und es noch diskutiert wird und ein weiter Weg bevorsteht, äh finde ich mal ganz interessant, was denn die.
Kategorien überhaupt sind, die.
Die Kategorien, die Artikel sind dreiundzwanzig Artikel, da sieht man direkt auch da Illuminaten, ne?
Oh. Da steckt auch was dahinter.
Da steckt auch schon wieder eine geheime Botschaft. Also Artikel eins würde. Artikel zwei Freiheit. Artikel drei Gleichheit. Artikel vier, innere und äußere Sicherheit,
Artikel fünf fünf Meinungsfreiheit und Öffentlichkeit, Artikel sechs Profiling. Artikel sieben Algorithmen.
Künstliche Intelligenz, Transparenz, Unversehrtheit der Wohnung, Datenschutz und Datensouveränität,
informationelle Selbstbestimmung? Datensicherheit, Wahlen, freier Zugang.
Netzneutralität, Pluralität und Wettbewerb Recht auf vergessen werden.
Besonders schutzbedürftige Personen, Bildung.
Arbeit im Materialgüter und Artikel dreiundzwanzig Schlussbestimmungen. Ja, das sind also die die Themen, die äh hier.
Die wollten unbedingt auf dreiundzwanzig kommen.
Ja, ja, die sind auch, also wenn man jetzt hier, ne, als als Forscher würde man natürlich sofort sagen, wir sind äh recht auf vergessen werden äh ist nicht äh
korrigiert mit dieser ganzen Datenschutzgeschichte oder Datensouveränitätsgeschichte. Das sind also die sind also nicht äh so hundertprozentig miesi und trennscharf.
Missi ist der Begriff, den ich übrigens hier ähm für die Big Five gesucht hatte.
Schreibst du wie.
Nee. Ja.
Müsste das heißen? Ne, MECE, also es heißt sie schließen sich gegen ein gegenseitig aus, also keiner ist Teil des anderen,
trotzdem decken sie alle Kategorien ab. Also erfassen das Feld vollständig.
Exclusive and Collective Lea Exhorstiv.
Collective Lea Ex Austr.
Genau, also sie schließen sich gegenseitig aus, aber in ihrer Gänze sind sie sozusagen umfangreich. Also vollständig.
Nee, F erfassen das genau vollständig. Vollständig und nicht überschneidend. Das ist äh das das scheint, dass äh das scheint bei den äh Big Five auch der Fall zu sein. Erschöpfen.
Erschöpfend war das Wort, was ich gesucht habe, genau.
Herrje, also Grundrecht Kater, bin ich mal gespannt, wie das weiterläuft.
Wie auch unsere Sendung hier, ne? Also ist auch.
Glaube ich, das wird die längste Loko Netzpolitik ever.
Ist sie bereits schon längst ja.
Sorry, wir machen zwei Teile draus. Äh Grundrechte, Kater gibt es, wir nehmen das zur Kenntnis und schauen uns das mal an.
Und was es jetzt auch gibt, ist äh Ford Crime.
Oh. Da hatten wir das nicht schon neunzehnhundertvierundachtzig irgendwan.
Hatten wir schon neunzehnhundertvierundachtzig und äh haben wir jetzt auch nochmal in Frankreich, denn da wurde ein zweiunddreißigjähriger Mann zu einer zweijährigen Gefängnisstrafe verurteilt, weil er mehrfach Webseiten besucht hat, die der Gruppe islamischer Staat
nahestehenden Stadt nahestehen sollen
ähm die rechtliche Grundlage für die Verurteilung ist ein im Zuge des Antiterror-Pakets erlassenes Gesetz äh ging das schon am Verfassungsgericht geklagt wird,
geil, hast du dich informiert, äh wer fährst du ein.
Das geil.
Da gab's auch mal so eine schöne Sendung über islamische äh Kultur äh Terrorpropaganda. In einem von deinen Lieblingspodcasts.
Ja, aber kann ich natürlich jetzt nicht mehr empfehlen, ne?
Nee. Die kommen noch in die Hölle, die beiden.
Die beiden kommen in die Hölle, also vor allem wenn ihr, also die sowieso, aber äh vor allem, wenn man sich das anhört, ne, also hört unter keinen Umständen. Äh jetzt muss ich mal, wie hieß der denn noch.
Metrolaut.
Metro Lot.
Kultur des.
Die Kulturindustrie hat, welche Folge war das? Fünfundzwanzig, Folge fünfundzwanzig, nicht Folge dreiundzwanzig. Ähm empfehlen wir heute hier heute auch nochmal nicht anzuklicken.
Ja, dürft ihr auf gar keinen Fall hören, weil könnte halt jetzt sein, äh, wenn ihr da zufällig in Paris äh äh gerade durch die Straßen lauft, dass ihr euch sozusagen eines Hirnverbrechens ähm.
Gedankenverbrechen sein.
Gedankenverbrechens, ein Gedankenverbrechen ist eines Gedankenverbrechens schuldig äh macht. Ich finde das wirklich hardcore. Also die Franzosen, sorry äh,
tendieren ja ohnehin zum überreagieren und äh so sehr ich Verständnis habe für eine ähm.
Aufgeheizte Grundstimmung auf Basis der äh starken, krassen Terrorakte, die dort im letzten zwei Jahren stattgefunden haben,
glaube ich nicht, dass es sehr hilfreich ist an dieser Stelle solche Zugriffe ähm zu machen, weil.
Klar kann sein, ja, dass es sich hierbei um jemanden gehandelt hat, der in irgendeiner Form geliebäugelt hat, et cetera. Aber es ist halt schon auch so ein bisschen, ist nicht nur so Gedankenverbrechen, es ist halt auch so ein bisschen dieses ähm,
diese vorhersage, ja? Also so dieses, wenn du das schon liest,
dann dann wirst du wahrscheinlich in Zukunft etwas Böses tun, was uns äh schade ist, ne.
Das ist Verhaltensvorhersage Tim.
Ja, da sind wir schon wieder.
Den Leuten, die diese Seiten lesen, haben wir mehr Terroristen als in der Gesamtbevölkerung.
Oh Gott. Also spätestens jetzt ist unser Podcast nicht mehr Metzi compliant.
Bist in der falschen, du bist in der falschen äh.
Baby an.
Auf der falschen Divension hast du einen hohen Score. Also ne, Big Five Plus Isis.
So ist es voll du.
So
Weiher.
So, jetzt sind wir schon fast am Ende. Jetzt noch ein paar ähm Housekeeping Sachen. Ich bin ja hier äh oft von dir auch ähm.
Zurecht darauf hingewiesen worden, dass wir hier immer ähm aus predigen wir weinen und äh.
Zuhause gab's dann doch nur Wasser.
Und saufen Schlaf.
Also Logbuchnetzpolitik gibt's jetzt auf jeden Fall äh auch im im Netz, so wie sich das äh gehört.
Sprich über das jetzt mit harte TPS gemacht und haben auch irgendwie diverse andere,
Diverse andere jetzt hier voll angeklickt, vor sechs Jahren schon länger und irgendwie hat die P zwei und überhaupt alles jetzt mal total
super und kryptomäßig. Ihr könnt euch das ja gerne mal anschauen, euren Senf dazu geben, wo ihr uns sonst immer so viele für ähm.
Nee, macht das nicht. Also ich sehe, du hast TLS eins null. Das heißt, du kriegst bei äh Qualis SSL-Labs sowieso schon mal keine guten Noten mehr.
Na ja, es kann sicher ist auch alles noch verbessern, ja. Man muss ja auch mal hier kooperativ rangehen, ne.
Ich sage nur, also wenn du wenn du Leute auch ein Feedback bittest, ähm kriegst du das.
Ja, du hältst dir das schon mal vorher angucken können, bevor ich mich jetzt wieder ins auf.
Ich halt, ich halte jetzt den Mund, weil.
Wenn wenn die Leute auf den Link zu meinem Blog klicken, werden sie feststellen, dass ich aus meinem eigenen Blog kein TLF habe.
Oho, ah, so.
Und ich wurde also auch da schon äh drauf hingewiesen und äh mir wurde da jetzt ein Quest äh für den dreiunddreißig C drei gemacht, weil sonst kommt die die Kryptopolizei und verhaftet mich.
So sieht's aus. Das ist ja schon totales Gedankenverbrechen, was wir,
alten Staat hast, ne? Ja, nee, also äh nebenbei äh auch jetzt gerade während dieser Sendung ist die neue Version von unserem Pot Love Publisher rausgekommen, der das auch ermöglicht hat, denn äh es gibt eine kleine Einschränkung gibt's die Podcast, die dürfen nach wie vor HCTP,
Muss euch nicht weiter interessieren, aber diese Ausnahme äh zu machen ist jetzt auch mit der Software möglich,
Und warum machen wir das? Weil irgendwie iTunes immer noch nicht sein Act zusammen äh hat und es irgendwie Podcast,
Feeds immer noch nicht ermöglicht, einfach mal auf HTPS zu leben. Es sei denn, man äh beugt sich dem ihrem Regime von fünf oder sechs empfohlenen Internetcompanys die Zertifikate ausgeben
anstatt das so zu machen, wie es alle anderen machen, nämlich das einfach alles, was irgendwie sich korrekt verhält, auch akzeptiert wird, ne? Al,
sie bremsen dort äh letztendlich aus oder zumindest die Podcaster und ich äh prangere das an.
Das ist äh ein großes ist tatsächlich ein Problem. Ja, der gerade äh also es ich höre von Podcasts, die aufgrund der Verwendung von äh letzten äh Zertifikaten inzwischen nicht mehr im iTunes verzeichnet sind.
Genau und damit halt auch in vielen Podcast-Clients nicht sind und das dieses Problems war ich mir immer bewusst und das war einer der Hauptgründe, warum es so lange gedauert hat und jetzt die technischen Probleme halt soweit überwunden. Es ist so.
Wie hast du es gelöst? Also einfach da du bietest weiter den Feed über HTTP an oder äh oder guckst du, wo.
Genau, also der der Server kann halt im Prinzip auf beides äh reagieren, aber äh nur für alles, was Feeds ist, Slash Feed wird sozusagen HTVP erlaubt und alles andere leitet automatisch auf HTPS weiter.
Die Mediendownloads auch.
Die Medien-Downloads waren eh auf einem anderen Server, sind aber jetzt auch HDPS. So, weil du musst gleich nochmal gucken, wie das jetzt gerade eingestellt ist, aber alles.
Musst du nochmal gucken, weil ja, ja, ich meine auf Twitter hat jemand das Gegenteil beurteilt?
Nee, nee, richtig, wir verlingen nee, weil dann hast du ja wieder Mix Content Problematiken und so weiter. Das ist halt äh das Problem.
Aber das heißt, wenn wer jetzt manuell einflägt, hat hier die PS-Lokometspolitik DE Slash Feed als Wall und der und einen Klein benutzt, dann tut ihr das oder nicht.
Wie gesagt, die Feedwahrnehmung ist, alles ist harte DP, aber die Webseitenwahrnehmung ist alles das HCPS.
Das sind diese Informationen, die euch eigentlich gar nicht äh interessiert haben, aber ich hab's jetzt einfach trotzdem mal gesagt, aber dich vielleicht interessiert so ein paar Leute bisschen, kennen sicher auch ein bisschen Sch.
Die meisten pennen ja jetzt eh schon, ich meine Sendung.
Das stimmt allerding.
Jetzt können wir auch bis morgen weitermachen.
Jetzt können wir alles erzählen. Na, wenn wir schon bei allem sind, dann äh machen wir nochmal unseren Nachschlag zum dreiunddreißig C drei, der nach wie vor ansteht Ende des Jahres,
Ähm kurzer Hinweis, es gibt ja dort auch ein Kidsbase, das heißt ein Ort, der ähm so gestaltet ist, dass er Kindern äh auf dem Kongress,
Spaß bereiten soll und vor allem auch die Gelegenheit sich dort zu betätigen. Und ich hatte, glaube ich, war das hier oder war das eine Freakshow, ich weiß nicht, hatte irgendwann mal so diese Lego-Idee bisschen in die Welt geworfen.
Wahrscheinlich bei der Frühshow.
Und jetzt äh hat das auch noch äh konkrete Folgen gehabt und vielleicht lest ihr euch mal den Blogpost auf Events jetzt dazu durch. Wir suchen nämlich ähm dort auch noch,
Duplo,
Steine, denn es gibt dieses Jahr nicht mehr einen Legofundus, auf dem wir in den letzten Jahren äh immer zugegriffen haben, wollen uns das aber einen eigenen aufbauen. Und wenn ihr noch Duplo,
Lego rumliegen gehabt zu Hause und hab Bock das zu spenden dann spendet das doch mal, weil wir würden da gerne,
riesige Dublo-Welt aufbauen, aus der man alles schön zusammenbauen kann, also für manche von euch muss man auch kurz erklären, Duplo, das ist sozusagen so mein Craft zum Anfassen.
Dem meisten muss man erklären, dass er nicht der Schokoriegel mit gemeint ist.
Oder auch das, genau. Also wir reden hier von dem Großlego und ja dann könnt ihr das an eine dort genannte Adresse senden und dann wird das sozusagen auf dem Kongress alles zusammenkommen. Und also es ist toll.
So viel dazu.
Was auch zusammen kommen soll, sind unsere Puzzleteile.
Das hatte ich äh schon vor zwei Sendungen mal erklärt und ich habe noch nicht alle. Also schaut nochmal nach, ob ihr die gelben Puzzleteile von LMP zweihundert bei euch seht.
Und wenn, dann bitte.
Fotografieren und mir schicken.
Ninus braucht das. Unbedingt.
Ja, dann war da noch was äh mit T-Shirts. Wir haben noch ein paar über und wir wollen die euch ja zukommen lassen,
Ähm da sind wir jetzt auf den letzten Metern das vorzubereiten und wenn's denn soweit ist, sagen wir auch nochmal Bescheid und dann könnt ihr hoffentlich sehr bald äh,
diese Shirts euch bestellen, sodass die auch noch so in diesem Jahr den Weg zu euch finden.
Genau, da wurde ja öfter nachgefragt, wir sind da mit Hochdruck dran,
das das dafür zu sorgen, dass äh ihr die noch vor Weihnachten äh bekommen könntet, theoretisch, wenn die Post die dann liefern würde.
So, am Ende dieser Marmutsendung danken wir. Martin Thorsten, Markus Lars, Martin Wolf Rüdiger und einer äh unbekannten Person.
Steck kein Name dran.
Okay. Ja genau, wir wir danken dem Unbekannten Hörer, der unbekannten Hörerin,
für das Hören von Lok Buchnetzpolitik. Auch wenn's mal so eine lange Sendung ist, aber na ja Gott, wir senden ja nur jede Woche und es gibt einfach so viel zu wieder zu Coin.
Ja, wir tun es da, ich soll es liegt einfach daran, dass ich hier mit diesem mit wahrscheinlich ist der längste Teil dieser Persönlichkeitspsychologie teil, ne? Wo man merkt, dass ich da lange nicht mehr drüber geredet habe über.
Ja, ja, du, äh, damit hast du jetzt auch unser Projekt darüber mal ein CIA zu machen, irgendwie schon komplett torpediert.
Äh
Beiden Formate verschmelzen hier auf einmal.
Jetzt bin ich. Hör auf, mir immer die Schuld daran zu geben, dass du nur noch so selten die Juwelen vom Himmel herabreiß.
Ich kann's gleich hinsetzen und äh das Ding machen.
Muss auch nochmal was anderes machen.
Wir machen jetzt mal was anderes, Leute. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Vielen Dank. Tschüss.
Vielen Dank. Tschüss. Ciao ciao.